gonna just pearly things YouTube
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from them than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though but it goes
so deeper though because I know what
you're talking about and he has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest
unders for women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's picky or men or women
men women are more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept more than men do you think men
are very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry it
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last oh I I done
an only fan but it wasn't like designer
boobs it was lingerie yeah builds right
whatever I'd done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not going to if
you don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not high
respect for yourself
yeah
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and it's that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these live streams also guys
as you already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show um the first is that we have
two clips channels uh just Pearl eclipse
and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both also guys we have four
membership tier um the first tier lets
you be a part of the chat tonight and uh
King how many likes do we need to open
up the chat tonight
a thousand okay so we need a thousand
likes to open up the chat tonight so
make sure you hit the like button also
guys if you want to see me freestyle rap
sign up for our second tier for our
behind the scenes Vlogs third tier you
get to
um connect with me on social media and
fourth tier you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month do you want to know
how to get a million subscribers in a
year sign up for the fourth tier
um that's my favorite one and I
recommend that
um also guys
um they took away my Instagram so go
follow my new one I'm just pearly things
one I'm also banned on my first second
third fourth and fifth Tick Tock so go
go follow my new one which is just
pearly things
um also guys subscribe to wife school we
have a new episode of wives school where
I learn on what I would cook for a
family of four in a day
um so which is like four kids so I guess
a family of six but um and I literally
cook for everyone that works here so and
they they rate the food and they give me
honest ratings so go check that out
that's on wife school also guys we have
an animation Channel just pearly
animation so we have two Talent channels
so make sure you go subscribe to King
Richard she's an Auntie Jenny they both
do lives when I'm not live basically and
um any other announcements we got I
think that's pretty much it yeah okay um
welcome to the show everybody I'm happy
to have you here um to start we're gonna
go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself and you know what
let's add where you're from today so
starting here awesome my name is Carmen
Habibi I'm originally from Sudan I am 35
years old and I'm single and I forgot
the other things but I'm a personal
faith and that's the perspective that
I'm going to bring in today
so you're from Sudan originally yes yeah
that's what I love about the show is it
literally like I can meet someone from
all over the world it's so cool that's
what's so cool about London um go ahead
hey um so my name is elham marus and I'm
originally from Iran see this this is
something actually and um
uh sorry what what was the other
question ah fun fact
um I think um I love to be with no
filter no filter dancer I think um
especially with social media we all have
filters and I just that's one of the
reasons I love podcasting just to be you
know real and fun okay great uh
relationship status uh I have a partner
um we just got engaged as a habit we
still call each other partners but we
are um basically Fiona I have a fiance
so yeah okay great oh go ahead my name's
Samantha I'm 46.
I am from Manchester I'm half Brazilian
um this is the most diverse Couch today
and
um I have a partner
um and I work a lot in the aesthetic
field and and that's me okay
my name is Mandana I'm 43 years old I'm
single
um born in Iran raised in Sweden uh fun
fact
um I don't know I play football coach
football and I roller skate
my name is Gary gimado I'm 31 years old
um I was born arrested in Italy
31 taken fun fact about twin sister
my name is Adolphus sounds like I'm
unsure my name my name is Adolphus I'm
30 married
uh born in America originally lived in
England since I was free fun fact I too
like to roller skate
hey guys um I'm Alex I'm byamba I'm 35
years old
um I'm single and uh just recently
started my property management company
called am Global let's cheap luck
welcome to the show guys so
um today's topic is what would you give
up for the right guy and man what would
you expect the right girl to give up for
you
so
um what do you give up in a relationship
well I have a lot to give so as a lot to
sacrifice because I'm a personal faith I
do follow Traditional Values of Faith so
there's a lot of me on the line
for me to give up and
um yeah it's uh it's obviously like the
sexual side so I uh you know in
Christian faith you you wait until
marriage Okay so
I'm willing
to wait for that man that high value man
yeah and that's a lot to give up okay so
you would give up waiting for marriage
or like not give um you would like have
him wait
oh I wouldn't give that oh okay I
understood this right yeah yeah I'm
sorry I understood this way so I'm
saying yeah
no no I would never give up this for any
high value man waiting till marriage
yeah okay are you a virgin
yeah oh really yeah I never thought I
would disclose this so publicly but yeah
oh okay okay so you want to wait until
you're married yeah okay
um would you give up let's say like
social media
yeah that wouldn't be a problem yeah I
would give up
hold on
that's actually really good I think I
think in that culture is that's what
they have to do so I think when she has
to
um do certain things that they have to
give up social media they can't present
themselves in certain ways so I think
when you say would you give up the
high-end man
then we have to look at it perspectively
above board as how would we do that of
women of different cultures
so her culture they wouldn't be able to
do that well you guys don't have social
media no I'm on social media but uh yeah
I grew up in a Sudanese Arabic culture
which is very strict however I lived
most of my life in Germany I live here
in a very modern society so I did get
influence from here as well not just
from my background but
um in terms of I think it's not the it's
high value Menace we were speaking about
this earlier Pearl and I would love to
have your perspective as well as how do
you define a high value when and how do
you define a modern woman because the
way I Define a high value men may be
very different than you define it and
then they Define it so the way I Define
a high value men is somebody who is
Faith driven who is a respectable who's
got
um yeah he's got Integrity so it's it
values but it's also he definitely has
to have a job for sure make money but
there's other aspects I look for and
have element for me to give up something
anything what does he bring to to the
table as well well so I would Define
high value men as the men that women
pick
so like the men that women routinely go
after and choose and Kevin Samuels
actually is the one who coined that term
so he he laid it out
um it's 10K per month he has to have had
that for three to five years
um other men must accept him as high
value he has to have a network of high
value men he has to be LinkedIn
visibility level and he must be useful
to others in the group
so that's the definition yeah yeah would
you agree that's what we have to take
into account different cultures
different people's Lifestyles how that
you his is his lifestyle that's not my
lifestyle that's not her lifestyle
that's not his or his or different
cultures so we can have a statistic that
says that but you can't truly say that
and I think we need to be open when we
ask that question because we live in a
very diverse world right now I can't
truly say that um because women only
swipe right five percent of the time on
dating apps and we typically pick the
same men
um so I will go on a date in up and I
would never pick my man on a date enough
I mean if you if you even at a bar you
see women approach or like go after the
same type of guys
how would you know that initially the
average woman yeah no no no I don't know
how would you know that list you asked
that person that was going into the bar
what type of guy are you approached to
and you can watch you can see who they
go after and the most statistics come
from
um so where where do my Stats come from
there's different studies that talk
about this it's pretty cut and dry on
like Tinder Bumble like there's so many
dating and even and even if you wait
wait I'm trying to answer your question
so and even if you go off of dating apps
like I do it on the show where we could
go through you guys one by one and put
out what you want in a guy and it's
usually less than 20 percent of men I
think that's a human that I want in a
guy X Y inside is no I'm saying in
general in general that's I think that
is the key Point well the average is
that your average but that's why she
says most people are average okay well
then I probably maybe because I've
looked at it what people would give up
um and I think it's subjective so how
would we How would we look at us and add
an average woman what would you say is
an average woman then
average to me is going to be different
to what Alex thinks is average to what
Gary fix is everything
like statistically there is an average
or like in general I get that but who
says who sets the statistics
what Paul will say like from the dating
apps which part are you asking about the
women are you asking about the heights I
looked at statistically a thousand men
and they said to me
this is what they would prefer you're
going to prefer my report or you can
prefer somebody that's going to say to
you well you know what this is what I've
done and this is what I've looked at and
this is what I found
um I would probably go buy experience
and studies which are usually pretty
similar like if I put up lizzo most guys
will probably pass
um
yes yeah
yeah over
oversized women are coming back right
now and I I probably for women to who
well from mine maybe not you but for a
lot of men she does
when we're sat here laughing and we're
sat here laughing and like
do you know the percentage of the
population about how many women are
oversized too many do you know too many
it's like there's more well listen I
work in medicine and sat on weight and
stuff and I see a lot more oversized
women and they're trying and if you see
the adverts that we see on TV from marks
and Spencer Tesco's a lot of them
that doesn't mean that they're the women
that men desires okay so are you guys
sat here underway with a six AB
s that's not a discussion here well
that's what I'm asking for you why are
you asking them what's your point stick
to the facts because if you're
commenting on oversized women you're
trying to decide for men what they like
and you're not really in a position to
do that I'm trying to not being a man
that shoot they shouldn't be
um
you don't think you
should discriminate in who you date
I don't think you should discriminate
against anybody yeah but so so you want
you want to you want a short broke guy
five five choose okay unemployed why I
do there's some crackheads down the
street I can set you up with should I
tell you okay
I'm dead serious but let me tell you I
make my choices so I decide to choose
who I want to date because I think you
decide you want to choose you want to
date you and you do right it doesn't
matter what it bases on it's based on
what I like
and we're talking a
do you think you and lizzo have an
equally attractive body
do you think you do I think I have a
better body than lizzo do you think you
and do you think you've ultimately just
discriminated yourself from her
how well you just said you have a better
body yeah that's not discrimination
I don't think it takes much time let me
do when we talk about
color against white and black ice matter
do we not discriminate or do we want to
not have that conversation or does it
now suit you better because we're now
talking about size it's not healthy so
yeah it's only from that perspective
it's not just about how she looks There
Is Now They are promoting
that it's fine being overweight it's
healthy because it looks good and that
no it you're right it is her choice to
be overweight but that's not a good
choice for health it's not a good job
selfie facts the slimmest person who
you'd think would look the healthiest
could have could unhealthiest lifestyle
and she might just have a percentage of
body fat because she just eats
differently did you look at that did you
know that um obesity drops after like
the age of 65. you know why that is
how many people live until they're 65.
no the obese people don't that's why it
drops because they die oh we'll see look
at that damn snacks no yeah I'm serious
that's that's a fact
that's a stats
anyway can I say I will not give up
football it's pretty much the only thing
I wouldn't want you to either and you
know what I'm gonna be I'm just sat here
being real I'm not trying to show up to
any I'm just being real and the facts
aren't like my partner's cousin is a top
Cardiologist in El Paso so he'll tell
you with what pressure weight just does
on your heart and we want to go down
that road let's talk about medicine
we'll talk about in a real world not
just on
anybody's facts and show let's talk
about the medicine statistics
I'm a personal trainer so I've been in
Fitness industry for 15 years and um
most of my clients are are moms after
having a baby and they're overweight and
we always I'm a health coach so always
talk about that but the only thing is
they are they're very upset about their
ways because they think most of them are
single because they're overweight and
they just want to lose weight because of
you know they want to look good they
want to look confident and therefore
they want to find a good looking guy so
I don't think there is any problem when
we talk about
um you know people with you know
overweight people because they are
actually they love to talk about it
because they think because of social
media because of let's say even
Victoria's Secret right now having like
overweight beautiful ladies um
advertising bikinis and I love it
because I feel like now it's all the
women women around the world with any
size any color any shape they can you
know be seen I hate it
why when they have overweight women as
models because I want to be inspired
when I see a model I don't want someone
that like it's bigger
you finish my conversation but imagine
if I was overweight I mean I I used to
think like you I used to think oh but I
think we need to be inspired like as a
personal trainer I had a colleague who
was very overweight and I always
thinking I didn't want to be mean and
say you're a personal trainer you're
supposed to be the person inspire people
you're supposed to be really fun I would
agree yeah which you are very like you
have a
percentage of fat that is not acceptable
as a trainer but now I'm coming to a
point maybe I'm getting older with lots
of experiences some people really can't
lose a really good you can't assume
people that well you can't stereotype
them they can't lose weight they can
reduce oh my God I can't believe we're
going back into that like the 60s
what don't I understand so you don't
understand about genetics Health weight
how the body analysis well if you did
too then you wouldn't have made that
comment yes I would you still I still
make that comment because nothing's
impossible you can because then you have
to look at then you need to go to these
women that can't do that and ask them
who we all wanted have you asked them I
do hope these women lose weight
absolutely no have you asked these women
that can't lose weight have you asked
it's not true if they work with me they
can
it's not true that they can't how can
you say that that's like saying it's not
possible for someone to be healthy I
refuse to believe that that's just not
right that's just giving up on so in our
room who is sat with now who do you
think's the unhealthiest I don't know
look around at the room
you said a minute though it doesn't
doesn't necessarily come down to how
they look
[Music]
come to her and let her train you and
show you regardless of your ages
regardless of your sizes and let's put
it out there are you a trainer no I'm
not a trainer what do you do you do you
do life coach yeah yeah I'm a sports
therapists
plug the socials yeah I don't do social
media the recommendations I've been
doing it for over 20 years
telling me her story
stereotype again
okay okay okay
you can't ask men what they want and
when they say not lizzo you you say
you're stereotyping but women women
women don't like broke men we don't like
short men we we discriminate why can't
why can't men understand I don't care
about if you're because I make my own
money all right so first of all what
does things to do with anything so I
made my so I don't need to buy if he's
broke and he's nothing of is that okay
no Dave Bones have fun
let me finish my question but let me
finish my answer please I like somebody
to just treat me right and if that's
wrong
then a lot of women but what can you
define as being treated right will vary
because of those okay
now this is this problem called rich
rich life or whatever the woman earns
the most money she's being cost because
she's just cost a husband because he
stays at home and looks after the kids
that's us then five percent of
relationships
a lot of women stay at home and look
after the kids if you have children do
you have children no I don't have kids
and when you do then you then we can
probably make us decision I have a 24
year old daughter I've been down that
road okay you've been down what road
stop bringing up a child I don't even
think I need to explain yeah I just
you're being very random so I don't know
what that has to do we're talking about
obesity and now you're saying I had a
kid no I'm no no don't try and switch it
what I'm saying to you is when we're
looking at we just changed the com you
know I'm not even gonna go down the road
there is no there is no conversation
yeah okay let's hear the man see what
they actually it was so funny I'll stick
up for you when I was getting married
about when I was 22 the first two things
I said to my mom the guy I'm gonna be
married to first of all it shouldn't be
short yeah fat and bold and I got
married to a same person who was fat and
who was both and I got divorced after a
few years obviously but I'm just saying
I think
um that was my I think everyone is
allowed to choose whether they want to
be with someone tall obviously I love to
be with a man who is tall yeah
everyone's everyone's allowed to choose
but we all know that women prefer men
with good jobs
no they don't no they don't know
perspective right you've got four women
on this panel okay so let's do the
experiment what's your perspective what
would you like about okay this isn't
your show so I'm not okay so all right
so yeah okay okay
okay okay
um so so couch just raise a hand I'm
just curious do you prefer men with jobs
or no job so job raise your hand for
jobs jobs okay she's difficult we don't
we don't care about that so okay
um do you prefer men five photos
I mean you're annoying so okay so five
foot five foot or six foot six six six
okay you know five foot how many minutes
yeah I mean this is fine uh see they're
not offended are you guys offended
I don't know how come they're not
offended right now because they're on
your show but they'll be offended when
they leave outside
so now
I won't be a spot why wouldn't you want
us to answer her questions she just
asking all these questions man
five foot six foot how tall are you
what's the mile just answer the question
I'll tell you just answer the question
so are you gonna be interested seven how
tall are you I'm taller than you how
tall is that over five seven
how tall are you taller than five seven
foreign
how tall are you five foot six foot
how tall are you well when you want to
have a question it's not even my shirt
why are you asking me that's good do you
want no I didn't ask you're high I said
would you date a guy that was five foot
or six foot if you had to pick two guys
same guy okay look no you don't no sense
I'm asking five foot or six because I
don't okay if you're not if you're not
going to answer the questions you can go
because it's very disruptive I I don't
five six or five seconds
no I said five foot or six foot
okay okay so you like tolerance what a
surprise okay job or no job
it depends what they can provide no job
or no job would you rather than this
unemployment on benefits or a guy with a
job come on what if he's got no Japanese
doing it it depends when you say no job
your man's got a job unemployed yeah
I got one for you okay thank you so so
women do you prefer amount of money and
okay thank you now the men men okay
would you rather have a girl that was
300 pounds or 120 pounds 120 pounds okay
okay thank you so we can speak in
generalities and the whole couch agreed
okay thank you
um so what would you give up for the
right guy
yeah because we all agree that you have
to make sacrifices in relationships
right so what sacrifices are you willing
to make in a relationship
you know what we had we just had the
conversation before you came and we were
talking about if we see ourselves as
modern women and independent woman and I
made a transition I used to think I was
a misindependent modern woman but the
recent years I've made that transition
and I never thought I would give up
my career
uh you know just like on being in a high
position I was looking when I was young
I was always looking for a status I was
looking to go up the career ladder
making money but over time it has
changed I think now I'm getting old and
I'm like hey have I been wasting some
years do you think you have uh now
looking back no I like I
I don't like to think so but if I would
were to go back and do some things
different I would but I don't regret it
because that has added to my experience
now what would you do different
well don't listen to songs like Neo Miss
Independent first of all
right okay right and I think it's like
this music culture and yeah it's so sad
I I would have gone back and gone spoke
to my aunties more spoke to my mom more
from Sudan the traditions because I see
my my parents are still married my
grandparents are still married
and I I would have I wanted to rebel
against that when I was younger now I
made that transition and I'm thinking
I'm not that independent woman I don't
want to be an independent woman anymore
so I would
if it's the right man I believe that the
right man we have we have aligned
visions and missions so
um I'm willing to give up everything I
had in my career to go what for what God
has put us together as a mission
together I would do that yeah so you
would give up your career for a family
say
I would if God wants me to do that I
would yeah so one thing you said you
said you don't regret it
uh are you do like if I were to go back
I would do some things different but I
am grateful for where I am at right now
so I'm grateful that I had this
experience now I have a little niece I
can teach her those things so she
doesn't go the road that I went to but
um I just never understand when women
say they don't regret it if they would
change it because then wouldn't you
regret it
I don't understand you like I've heard
girls say that and it doesn't compute to
me because me if like if I would change
something then I regret a certain
decision well it's uh it's the feeling
if you don't like the outcome if you
don't like the outcome like why don't
you regret it
to be honest Pearl I don't I again like
I'm I'm not gonna apologize for I'm very
Faith driven so I speak from that
perspective and
um regret is a very it's it's a very bad
feeling and it's I don't believe that
we're meant to live with regret so
before I was regretting it for sure I
was feeling those regrets I was feeling
those oh I shouldn't have done but then
because I'm safe now because I have a
different life now I don't carry those
feelings anymore I'm set free from that
so yeah if I if I was it was why would
anyone want to live with with regret and
why would that be comfortable for
anybody to live with regret and why
would you anybody see that I don't
mention like a way that lives in a way
that shames but to me like when I hear
that it just sounds like the same thing
that was my question because if I would
change something and I regret it well
regret if you live in regret it's like
you're holding on to something then you
can't at the same time be grateful for
who you are now what you've got oh so
it's kind of like just not living in
like the shame of the decision in the
past they said okay I did that and like
um sorry was it common yeah yeah she was
saying it's it's what she's learned from
it so how can you regret that it's like
wow I've learned from if I didn't go
through this part path I wouldn't even
know I could have no I mean I could
absolutely look at certain decisions
that I've learned from and be like well
um
you can't change it yeah but yeah I get
what you're saying there are certain
things that yeah I wish I did not do
that I did not need to learn in that way
I could have learned from other people
but so yeah so you mentioned you went
from being more modern to being more
traditional um what what did you do
specifically
um to make that change yeah so uh when I
when I came here when I went to Germany
I lived in Germany most of my life and
then I came to the UK so I was more um
the culture has changed so I wasn't into
very traditional I wasn't so close to my
Sudanese background so I was more around
people who were living a very modern
life and there's a lot of my friends to
wear with single parents so in my
culture it's not this is not happening
and
um that has shaped who I was becoming so
you didn't surround yourself with modern
people no I did I did no I'm saying now
you chose to switch it to more children
so now I have empathy
okay now I have I can understand why
they're living this way and why I
rebelled against my roots and who I came
from but I made that transition so
because I saw this yeah so I I saw this
freedom I saw this empowered woman I can
be everything I can do everything
but that comes with a price so uh maybe
because you moved from your country to a
more Western and more free country could
it be that yeah yeah for sure for sure
yeah Western uh country has definitely
shaped me and I have to be honest not
for the best way how old were you when
you came to the UK from Germany three
years three years old three years yeah
from now when I came from Sudan to
Germany from Germany to UK how old was
he I think 18 19. okay
yeah so I still don't understand what
you did to become more traditional
so I had examples
um and I didn't see successful marriages
I didn't see successful relationships so
uh then I started to surround myself
around Christian communities when I
became a personal faith and I got
baptized in 2019 that completely
transitioned my life so as a result I
started to see successful healthy
marriages I didn't see that before
that's why I didn't even have the desire
to be married you didn't see it I
thought you said your parents and your
grandparents were married yes but that's
the only example that I had that's a
very limited example
but I didn't I didn't okay they're
married but do I want to have their love
life no
uh they're still together their values
are amazing when when hard times hit
yeah they're sticked together but I want
it more so I didn't have those examples
but when I I started to surround myself
in the right environments and I started
to see that I can have healthy
relationships and healthy marriages and
um yeah with the right files so that has
changed it's surrounding myself the
right people who I can see an example
all I needed was just an example in role
models and I didn't see it so yeah so
this it still doesn't make sense to me
and I hear this a lot but like when I
hear girls talk about how they were
modern and then they became traditional
yeah like I don't hear anything that you
actually did like I hear that I
surrounded I got baptized which is great
you know I'm you know Pro Faith here and
and and like that you surrounded
yourself with people that were married
but it's like I can watch people that
play basketball that doesn't mean I
learned to play so I was just wondering
like what specifically you did to become
because if if women want to know you
were modern before then you became
traditional like what specifically did
you do
well there's for something new to come
in the old has to go my old self had to
die so that means my old belief so
because you said you you know of Faith
right do you know something called the
Holy Spirit
so when the Holy Spirit convicts someone
on something when you know you have a
conviction people call it intuition
we call it the Holy Spirit
so but it's it's stronger it speaks so
clearly it's like
this thoughts feels wrong the person
like I remember the day well this was
crazy I remember the day before I got
baptized this was crazy I was with a
atheist guy
I was dating an atheist Guy and
um I I was like yeah I can change him
whatever and the day after I got
baptized and I had this inner conviction
I had to break up with this person of
course for obvious reasons but did
someone from outside come and tell me
this no it was an inner conviction I
knew that I had to let go of certain
people certain beliefs because my faith
is is now the priority I'm fully sold
out no and I think faith is great right
I think I think that's genuinely great
for you but Faith like getting baptized
being taken over with the Holy Spirit
like I've been baptized that didn't make
me traditional yeah right so yeah like
what did you physically do can you just
Define traditional maybe I don't
understand
traditionals like our grandmothers and
our great grandmothers that's that's
like traditional
because I don't see myself traditional
traditional but I don't see myself
modern so is there like a middle
definition or hybrid that's
um I I don't I don't really think so um
I think it's like a lot of no offense to
you modern women pretending to be
traditional and some of them don't
really know they're not but I think I
think once you like are around like a
truly traditional woman you just know it
when you see it I I think there's
differences because you can be around
like you're saying traditional you can
you cannot be and I think that put that
individual person grows up to believe
and do what they believe in their faith
and whatever they choose but but you can
like believe things and that's that's
great but it's about what what you do
yes right exactly I see a traditional
woman like would dress a certain way
like I agree with that yeah you know it
wouldn't show off and wouldn't go out
partying drinking
um yeah would be at home yeah
how do you see a traditional women
because in different even in the UK of
different parts there's different parts
of if you look at Liverpool if we look
at Travelers everyone has a traditional
type of how they bring if you look at
must any culture they all have a
different traditional way and and in
their life they have different
Traditions but I would still say the
archetype of a traditional woman is the
same yeah
if you look at it no no no no no no
if you look up The Travelers they
they're very crisp no no no they're very
strict they're very prominent they're
they're Travelers that that is nothing
I'm just saying they're part of
traditions they're traditional women
I don't know anything we don't really
have those in the U.S
we actually don't actually we don't
no no no no I don't get an education
they literally have to like get married
at a very young age and have children oh
okay yeah okay no we don't we yeah but
we don't call let's not get this we
don't call them that let's be very call
them up
they're very strategic in their belief
they're very they're in their faith and
how they're brought up and what they
believe in as the same as a Muslim woman
a Muslim culture is a Catholic culture
is a Hindu culture is a Buddhism of
course there's different types of
traditional women yes okay and they're
all fall into the same so we can't we
can't sit here and say okay so we're
gonna we're gonna have to go back and
forth all night if you're gonna talk
about there's different types of people
like that's the general
stereotyping yeah stereotype a lot so
we'll get over it okay okay so well um I
I don't need to get over that I mean you
do have to get over it if you want to
stay so oh okay I stereotype on the show
yes okay
men do like thin women that's yeah thank
you
um okay so
um
what did you say what you did to become
traditional uh sorry the only thing that
stuck to my head you said something
really interesting which is submission
and I think this is the big difference
in the western culture with other
traditional cultures because traditional
cultures are more uh receptive to this
concept of submission and I think a lot
of times in the western culture we are
um they don't really know what that
means and this is why there's the
conflict that's that's just what I
wanted to say okay but to add on that
what submission is
is you know we see like sometimes the
love as it's one-sided you know I wanna
I'm gonna give him this so I can get
this but actually true love is not I'm
gonna give this to get this a true love
is sacrificial love and I love the way I
agree I thought we're gonna not disagree
no okay I think that the most like
selfless people get the most in general
yeah yeah and this is I think this is
the uh and it's sacrificial love so
submission if a man is submitted to his
cause to his purpose to his mission to
God you know a woman can submit to him
can feel comfortable to submit him but
the problem that we're facing right now
in culture is that women don't feel safe
to submit to men because men are not
submitted to a cause or to a purpose and
this is the reason why their women don't
feel
you know safe to be sub submissive oh
because of the man could you say that
one more time
that men are not what's hard yeah so
when we talk about submission you know
uh we women our natural desire is to
submit our natural desire no matter how
much a woman wants to fight about it we
want to submit but the reason why women
don't submit because I know I was like
this as well and I'm still like this
actually a man needs to be submitted too
and man doesn't need to be submitted to
a woman but a man needs to be submitted
to a cause to a purpose and to Faith or
to God and this is where a woman needs
feels safe to be submitted yeah but
there are men that do that and I guess
the question is like why are you picking
men or I mean not you but if you're in
that situation why are you picking men
that don't have that this is really good
and you know what I put my hands up and
I do this mistake because wouldn't you
guys agree that men will do anything to
get laid
so it's like if the men if the men are a
certain way yeah it's like because we're
not rewarding good behavior yeah
but you know what we're in it we're in a
society now well women know they're the
same women do what we'll do anything to
you have fun have sex a lot of women now
I don't know if you realize how old are
you
um I'm 26. okay so I'm 20 years older
than you a lot of women now in their 40s
plus don't really kind of want that
whole thing they just want to go out and
have fun play the game yeah it's really
sad actually they should be married and
like at home but they're in the street
well when you get to that age tell me
how sad you are no I I well if I'm in
the streets at 40 so yeah I will be not
in the streets I have a very lifestyle
I wasn't talking about you I didn't
think you were but you said it was very
sad so I'm saying to you you feel that's
very sad then when you get to our age
then that's what I'm saying yeah that I
would be sad
if I was 46 and not married
when you're 46 years it doesn't
necessarily mean you if you're 46 or 50
or 55 if you're not if you're single
you're not going to be happy I don't
believe that yeah I agree with that true
yeah you you might not but I would I
would be really sad because um
I mean I'd either be childless or
divorced so either maybe because yeah
maybe because of course maybe I'm just
depending yeah
I choose not to be married
you're not single you said there's women
that choose not to be married and they
choose not to have children they also
choose to go on antidepressants
or your daughter that should have been
on your our show tonight and I think we
could have addressed that but she's not
here
unfortunately you could always get a cat
what you can always get a cat about a
little 24.
yeah but I don't think I'm allergic to
cats
well there you go
but I don't know but you actually choose
to be single and not have children I
think they end up would it have been
missing yeah it's like would you would
you rather be with a guy that okay show
a hands would you rather be with a guy
you love respect
people wait I'm asking the four on my
couch okay so um all right so so would
you rather be with a guy that you love
respect and admire and are attracted to
or would you rather be single so okay
lady Lady this is a call this is a hand
this is a hand okay okay
if you don't raise your hand for one you
can go you can either cooperate with the
show or you cannot cooperate it I'm
gonna okay the reasons why I'm not
coming because I don't think that
because this isn't this isn't your show
you can't be your shop but I'm just
saying that's my perspective so you can
you can cooperate or you cannot
cooperate also what you tell me is I
have to agree with you no I'm saying you
have to answer questions two options I'm
on I'm on a show I would understand if
it's something personal so this isn't
crazy I can put my hand up or I can say
no she wants you can you can either
choose one you have to choose one okay
okay all right would you okay I feel
like I'm talking to like a 10 year old
right now I'm listening to them okay
all right so would you rather be with a
man that you love respect and admire
and are attracted to raise your hand
yeah okay right now would you rather be
alone raise your hand thank you
um so so by that logic women over a
certain age it's not a choice to be like
most women over a certain age would
rather be with somebody honey I think
you're going to get a lot of butt Flack
on that one I really do I feel like it's
gonna come inside
all right guys guys uh
if you interrupt me one more time you're
going
you're going man okay
um so so guys over the age of 50 would
you rather be with a girl that's hot
submissive
and young girl than you
um or would you rather be by yourself
the first one the first yeah okay like
what the guys don't argue with this it's
easy
most people I don't think guys want to
be alone either no
okay
um what are we talking about so did you
ever did you tell me what you did to
become traditions
2000 I just want to know what you did
you took cooking classes you decided
that you're going to do XYZ you gave up
social media what did you do yeah did
you
how do you explain the Holy Spirit girl
you know
okay so this is what this sounds like to
yes now I'm not saying this is what
happened to you I'm saying this is this
is what it sounds like yeah so I hear
this and I hear nothing I got baptized
that's what it sounds like I got
baptized and now I'm traditional but
being getting baptized doesn't make you
traditional no I hear you uh yeah it is
I I think I started to explain it
earlier a little bit when I uh was
living in the western con Western
society and transitioned there I became
more modern but there's one thing I
remember my granddad he was um he taught
me from very young to not this is why
Pearl you made me share something that I
never thought I would share in public
but you know restaurants open
about
um saving myself before marriage so this
is the only thing I did I used to smoke
cigarettes 20 cigarettes a day I used to
Rebel in every way but this is the only
thing that I kept because I thought okay
if I'm gonna give this up I'm completely
away from my family and everyone else so
because my granddad and my my parents
instilled that for me from Young I
actually the way I did it was wrong as
well because the way that you you get
this thought it's like sex is bad right
or I don't know if I'm allowed to say
this one but sex is bad so this is it
was more like a fear base and that kept
me away which is not a healthy way when
I had an inner conviction after
um it is changing my environment it is
wanting more it is going into deep
depression searching you know you know
going up to Korea letter as a modern
woman Miss Independent and thinking that
when you reach that level you're gonna
be happy and then later realizing you
reach that level and you're not happy
and that's when I started to ask the
questions there's there must be more
maybe I'm not an independent woman maybe
there is more and it's by starting
asking those questions and you know just
searching for the truth desperately
trying to go from one thing to the next
until I realized this is It's My Faith
it's the only thing that can give me
full fulfillment that's how I made the
transition it's just
cigarettes it sounds like you stopped
going out I yeah we used to live in
London
um I lived in the UK and travel but
um yeah I used to live in London the uni
life did the clubbing scene uh which is
really tough as a you know when you
don't go to the next step with a man and
in it it always felt wrong even when I
was rebelling it always felt wrong
so I hope I answered the question yeah
is she is she leaving
is she gonna is she she either goes what
she wants a drink well have Helen give
it to her she's either in the bathroom
or she's sitting down
oh that'd be some more okay what purpose
water
um my girl's lit
yeah just I mean not I think she's had
enough alcohol okay
um okay
um thank you sorry
um what would you what would you give up
for the right guy
um
it's actually not easy for me to answer
that question I don't know because from
what I experienced because I got married
I um came from Iran to the UK and then I
got divorced I had a daughter I've been
single mom for eight years and I kind of
feel like for the last that eight years
living with my daughter
um it's kind of taught me a lot about
being independent I had to so I kind of
feel like I
um my personality build up quite a lot I
mean I felt like having a child and
because I've always been looked after
but my by my dad as a culture in Iran
and then I came here and I got married
so I was working but obviously I had my
husband so I think
um so I kind of understand her in a way
of tradition because when you live in
that sort of country that you've been
brainwashed since it was you were a
child that you know when you go out be
careful nobody should touch you this I
mean we have this in the UK as well but
you know that's a good thing it's a good
thing because I'm teaching that to my
daughter but we've been brainwashed in a
way of we've been so scared even when I
had a boyfriend I was like I was not
relaxed so I couldn't go on holiday with
him because I was I shouldn't sleep with
him and it was so kind of like so
confusing because you you grew up in a
different culture completely different
culture and now when I'm watching my
daughter at school she's 16. she's a
teenager she's going now she's going to
the like Brighton she's going without
with her friend I invite her friends
whether girl boy doesn't make any
difference to me anymore because I just
learned from her that girl and boy are
not making any difference if you're you
know going to school in the you know
mixed school but we never had that sort
of things in Iran so um don't you um
don't you think it's better like that's
a good thing to have less sexual
partners though like that doesn't seem
like a bad like you said brainwashed
like that was about brainwashed in a way
of um when I say brainwash I don't mean
like you know my parents kept me you
shouldn't have you know
sex with your boyfriend I was not even
allowed to have a boyfriend that's a
good thing no I don't think it's a good
thing at all because how did you get
married then it was arranged yeah it was
arranged and then you said you you also
I noticed something you said you said
you you had to be a single mother did he
file for divorce no I I filed it for
divorce so isn't that a choice then
um no it was my choice it was my choice
and I think if I was in Iran I would
have probably do it I wouldn't do it
because it was lots of family where
where right but right but when you said
like you had to be a single like you
said you you chose to be a single mother
and you had to be independent so yeah
that's not but that's not correct it
seems like unless there is some sort of
abuse or something
um no it wasn't an abuse at all we kind
of got to an agreement because it's been
um it was like two years that I wanted I
was thinking about divorce and then I
had a chat with my ex-husband and he
didn't want to get divorced but I wanted
to because I didn't want to live I
didn't want to be living with someone
who I am not here I don't love anymore
so I just didn't want to like the
feelings went away because did you love
him before did you never love him
um no obviously I loved him but I think
um it was so many different things he
told me because he wasn't arranged
wedding and we kind of did online at
meeting because I was in Iran and he was
in England so he was telling me for
example I'm very sporty and it was
saying I do horse riding I do tennis I
do this I do this and you know when I
when when we were together I was like
you said you're going to the gym every
day and you're doing this I mean I was
like I never seen you out of the house
and he was literally going to work and
coming back and sleeping on the sofa
watching TV so that was my life and I
never chose to to do that life because
even when I was back in Iran I was very
sporty I was very you know outgoing and
I love friends he never come out with my
friends because he was thinking he was
not social but I didn't really know
because we didn't really had a chance to
go out did you you know that before you
had a kid
um yeah yeah okay so then why did you
keep going if you you got because you
know that's a very good question why did
you keep going and then have the kid if
you do that's a very good question so
basically because I was scared to tell
my parents that I want to get divorced
and I didn't have I I wasn't I didn't
have a child that time and I was
thinking for two years how to tell them
that I don't want to live with him
anymore and I want to go I want to get
divorced yeah but you know what they
were telling me I think the reason is
because you're very lonely because
obviously it was difficult for me to
come from Iran which I had no friends I
had no one here and I only had him and
then it's difficult to um and recognize
whether I'm depressed and because of the
depression and I'm lonely and I'm
feeling you know out of my country I
don't have my family I don't have my
friends I don't have anyone and I was so
depressed I felt like could it be my
depression that I don't love him anymore
I don't want to be with him anymore or
maybe maybe if I was older and I was
more aware of what's happening if I had
some you know more experienced friends
telling me go to a psychologist go to a
coach and see what is wrong with you
maybe there's something wrong with you
but it was I didn't have any of those no
and I understand what you're saying like
the the what I'm disagreeing on is when
you said you you had to be a single
mother like you had no choice in it when
it seems like everybody I got your
question yeah no you had to be
independent but it seems like you chose
to be independent I chose to be
independent right so so it's like kind
of when we talk to the Next Generation
it's like sorry we make it seem like
there was no choice when it was all your
choice no actually you're right it was
my choice yeah so I I got divorced
without telling my parents
um and I got pregnant because it was
um I just thought my mom kept telling me
um you know you you need to have a child
maybe you won't be lonely and then you
know just don't because they don't that
time they never wanted me or even my
sister took a divorce I mean it was I
brought up in a very transitional family
do you have a daughter or son daughter
daughter was that hard on her her
parents going how old was she when you
guys got divorced three three years old
yeah so luckily she was very young to
completely understand what is going on
but I I I guess obviously she she got
hurt a few times especially when we were
having do you think that your the
culture that you come from yeah is what
gave you that fear of not wanting to
tell your mom 100 do you think if you
were still in that culture that you'd
still be married yeah and I'm so happy
that I break the ice and I kind of like
in my family I think probably I'm the
only one did that and after that
actually my cousins got divorced it's
kind of like become more yeah would you
say it's fair to say that women single
women kind of get help others in divorce
like you sort of inspired that divorce
or no
it's not not fair to say
um you mean you I inspired people to get
divorced yeah that's what I mean I've
just noticed in like um friend groups
that it's like one gets divorced and the
other than the other it seems like it's
almost I thought I I I I experienced
that I don't know with me if my friends
got divorced after me I I don't think so
but I think so many people say when a
friend get divorced normally people like
oh if she can do it probably I can do it
and to be honest so many girls they want
to get divorced what they want because
of so many things it can't be just
because isn't that a good thing
to be honest I I prefer to be single
than be in a really sad relationship
even if I have children yeah that's what
I think yeah like but to me it's like
isn't the kids feelings more and I'm not
even trying to shame you I'm just like
wondering what your mindset was yeah
because in my head it's like the kid is
more important than my feelings like
what made you consider your feelings
before the kid
um I I still
um even though I might look everyone's
saying you look so you know you're proud
of what you've done and that time I
couldn't say that so I was living with
my regret because of my daughter not
regret but kind of like shame it's a
better word for me to use it that time
when I got divorced I felt like oh my
God maybe maybe I shouldn't do it
because of her so everything was like I
shouldn't do it that's why it took me
two three years to make a proper
decision to you know apply for divorce
because I was I understand that because
I was so worried about my daughter yes
after my divorce it took me 10 years yes
after my splitting for my partner and
having my daughter
um that we we chose to get divorced
because we both had different partners
and I wanted the best for myself don't
say that again say what so when I got
divorced I'd already split from my
partner and I'd already been living in
London for a long time so you were
separated yeah for a long time for a
long time but I wanted the best for my
daughter and I used to be able to go
home to my partner's house and I'd stay
with them and have Christmas dinner with
them and I'd stay in my daughter's room
and I had the you know I can't say
everyone would have this but I was quite
fortunate that I had that relationship
because I wanted the best for my
daughter but do you not think the best
for your daughter would have been to
stay with her father no not if two
people are not truly in love with each
other and she sees us argue every day no
well no better solution to be wouldn't a
better solution be to just not argue
every day
well I'll ask you this when you have
children and you get yourself into that
position and you're truly don't you know
then you come back and let's have this
podcast again let's answer that question
again because I don't think could you
just answer the question like I
understand I don't have kids and you
keep bringing this up like you don't
have kids yeah okay I know so so my
question is do wouldn't a better
solution be to just not argue every day
for the kids because that's impossible
how is it impossible it takes two people
to argue
how many relationships
do people have like you can't you what
you're going to say well I did what was
the best for my child when I split up is
that me and my partner had the best
relationship I went let me finish I went
to my back call so I played the role of
the father as a poll as the as the
mother and the father and I spent every
month with my daughter I paid every
month I went there every month I made
sure she was okay from every day up
until she was 18 years old I made sure
she's had everything and she's still
here with me now and I don't know how
many fathers can truly say actually even
if they do that and when you have oh
okay so you're saying you you paid 100
for your your son or your daughter my
daughter you're not my daughter okay and
he didn't pay at all or he was he didn't
I did a reversed role so rather than the
father going off on leave the mother
went off and worked so it was just a
reversed role okay I was very fortunate
as well because neda's Dad my ex he
always I mean the first two three is
obviously because of divorce we were
going through you know Madness up and
down but after two three years that I
settled down with her and he he was
saying actually I'm not divorced because
I want to go around and look for boys he
actually he actually realized a really
good mom and we had to grow we right now
he's my best friend yeah he's my best
friend and Neda is seeing his dad my
ex-husband was my best every weekend so
it almost seems like it could have been
worked out if they were your best
friends no it's not the same to me um
because like I just this
it just it just okay have you got
children two
right so when you split up come back and
then and then well let me tell you
something
because I don't why would you wish up my
him splitting up because like right now
you're happily married and you've got
two children but there is no personal
responsibility look I was in a very
similar situation I'm gonna say I didn't
do everything that I could have done to
make sure that we stopped arguing it got
to a point where it could have gotten
really bad and my daughter was six at
the time I didn't find a way like you've
got to take some personal responsibility
instead of saying it's not possible
because I don't want people her age
to listen to us and be like oh well if
it doesn't work out we argue let's just
hurry up especially if there's kids
involved you've got to give them another
Choice like look I didn't have the
strength at the time my grandma who's 90
years old told me just the other day
like two weeks ago yeah that me and my
wife need to stay together regardless of
anything just for the sake of the fact
that we have a freedom I appreciate you
know what you know what you just hit the
nail on the head because I appreciate
what your grandma said at 90 years old
did she have Instagram did she have does
she have social media Instagram
no no no no no listen if my wife is
going to be tempted if my wife is going
to be tempted by you know Instagram on
why I'm married
no it's not just Instagram it's it's so
it's our social lifestyle to if you look
to the traditional marriage to look at
hours is that more important than
working on your relationship like
um
how social is it if you're just on your
phone scrolling
20 years
phone scroll on exactly and you could
have worked on different things no no no
no no no it didn't work that way because
we just weren't compatible no I didn't
know something
there's people okay there's people that
think that they're compatible they don't
so I'm not saying you did the wrong
thing but uh
millions of people that are going to ask
you why you think that they've done
wrong and they're going to come and say
to you good luck to you right now
I think that's right yeah
do whatever you can like do not give up
work on it like what his grandma said
like you've got to do whatever it takes
not just to stay married but to stay in
a healthy marriage I mean not like
staying and arguing yeah I don't break
up because of my daughter because I
didn't want her to see the arguments
don't
truth
one moment put your hands on me it's
time to go I'm thank you
thank you
go get your phone
yo what's going on Ellen didn't do
anything to you I was scared
what's going on
[Music]
oh my God
Gin and Juice boy
kids stay in school stuff Sam it's okay
just come out kids stay in school grab
her shoes stay in school kids
don't drink alcohol
I told her
I said what sorry that girl got a little
tea because she spoke to me
and I just said to her calm down yeah
you said it straight still I heard that
and then she tried that now but I'm not
upset and then yeah
yeah
I'm trying to Rattle people's kids
I hate that guy you know I just can't be
bothered anymore okay all right I think
the show starts out early yeah let's go
let's go let's have fun you can finally
get the answers too people will give up
for social media or for their
relationships
that's a virtue by the way
security
can you please sir you know
uh this is going to be a YouTube short
I'm sorry backstage Matthew said it was
going to go viral today man hey you guys
like And subscribe yeah have you heard
this experience
level four on the patreon
wow guys she's not from London by the
way she's from Manchester this is what
happened the Manchester Madness yeah
trust
him we'll just close up the door man
yeah this is mine thank you you just be
afraid about random bags in there yeah
oh boy
[Music]
shambles that grape alarm's gonna go
you're nearly a half a decade
literally she's the oldest one here but
that's what I had a feeling I had a
feeling Hey listen you hold your nerve
you know I'll be real I was like I
thought you were gonna get right much
sooner but can you get it I'm in the
show the show is called just pearly
things not just so meant for things no
just to help out with the show I'm happy
to sit in the middle there just there
you know yeah yeah that's fine yeah
guys there going to make sure that this
she's not giving her like she's gonna
give her stuff and like just make sure
it's not yours I'll talk to the guys for
now just to help out with the show pal
but I'm more than happy to sit there I'm
happy to sit down
the algorithm
um
he looks very unoccupied how quick like
women claim assault that's so cute like
it was assaulted I was like ridiculous
lady you wouldn't get up literally what
what I'm sure in the the DocuSign it
indemnifies my man from anything anyway
so it's fine yeah
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's about 10 there
uh actually I don't know which one it
was 11. yeah
do you have people live talking to you
there yeah yeah there's a chance
how many subscribers the live chats in
that man actually I think it was a
Showtime Showtime
um okay so what's up girl
wow that was crazy okay what were we
even talking about so all right
okay
all right starting starting here Alex I
don't think I've even heard you speak
once um what would you expect
um the right girl to give up for you to
be with you you know definitely the
socials okay you know nightlife
yeah and uh
Thanksgiving time that's it okay yeah
yeah so your big things are um social
media and nightlife nightlife yeah on
the all the whole behaviors of the
window all the whole behavior is gone
what do you want a waifah
okay what would you expect your girl um
to give up for you
um I'm pretty liberal like unless I see
that it's coming between us in some way
do what you want just don't be out here
making any of us look crazy because
you're a reflection of me
so if you're gonna go to the club with
your girls all right cool but then if it
if I if it comes back to me like you was
dancing on 50 men and your tongue was
down 50 throats then obviously it's not
gonna run can it because
one man too many I should be the one man
and if I'm not that obviously it's not
always that I can be there but like
she's dancing on another dude what'd you
mean you're dancing on a no she's at the
club
that's almost like a sarcastic refrain
but I understand what you mean by she's
dancing on on another one but like I
wouldn't appreciate that and if
yeah of course not working or nothing
nobody's thinking about it sure yeah
because you know it is now yeah
have you have you kept a girl before
that's done well yeah that's the thing
oh okay and I was like you know what
it's a dance if I she told me she did
tell me though so it's like cool you
told me
is it their worst thing in the world no
did I appreciate it no
you didn't marry me did you I did Mario
that's the thing oh she's the oh yeah
yeah this is my wife yeah okay yeah so
but then to be fair with my wife because
the story with my wife is a long time in
the making like I met my wife when I was
seven years old like so it's different
yeah you know so like you love it
exactly but enough I've said to her
before like if I just if I met you in
the club and then I found like you went
to the club and using other things in
the club it's like nah because I just
you're just any girl from the club so
you can go but she doesn't do that now
no no no she now and she's like she's
meeting her friends yeah go because
she's a wife she's a mother she's in
education stuff like she very rarely
goes out she looks after me Foods
clothes all that kind of two more
traditional relations very very to be
fair yeah so and yeah so that's that's
why I would question it but obviously my
situation is very unique is as opposed
to some other people out there but in
general terms then I would most people
say yeah okay
okay uh what would you give up for the
right guy
not soccer yeah pretty much my daughter
in football is like those two things I
mean why would a man want me to come up
football I mean yeah
um but I don't I mean I don't even keep
social media on my main phone I don't
don't they recruit you through Instagram
or no no just the girl knows me oh okay
okay she called me but um but yeah I
mean I'm yeah and gobby now is just over
I did a lot of clubbing when I was
younger I've lived my life scene I mean
I'm easy yeah whatever I don't have to
dress like a but then what if your
husband was like no yeah so you need to
hang up your football boots no more
lives no more life coaching just sit
down then we'll catch up and cook yeah
if it's the right man like sure I'm
bored of coaching anyway
seriously but yeah if he can provide
them so you go you won't give up you
just won't do it because you don't want
to do it anymore right
it's not like give up for him you're
you're coaching
well I am doing it now but yeah if he
really wanted me to give for the right
man yeah I would I'm not really attached
okay I have a question so this one I
actually don't even I don't even think I
would do this one so so would you get
plastic surgery no for the right guy no
absolutely I would not give up no no no
that I would not that doesn't really
make sense to me because if the guy
wants you to get plastic surgery why
don't you just find the woman who looks
like that's the way yeah yeah I've heard
I've heard guys like paying for their
girl's boob jobs yeah 100 yeah I've
heard of that but I'm too scared to
couldn't he just get the girl to eat
more not you can't get boobs from that
no yeah I mean you can put on weight
wouldn't wouldn't your breasts grow yeah
I don't think they want like I think
it's usually because they want the shape
I like glass yeah
I don't know
no you can't there are ways that you can
but not for it to look like plastic no
obviously not like it's not gonna be up
here but like but there are things you
like I said it is you can work on
yourself and get that I would do that
for him like to like work on myself to
be in shape to look good yeah absolutely
but not plastic surgery or fillers yeah
um okay what would you expect the right
girl to do for you or to give up for you
um I think you know sort of to begin
with
um just to look at my current
circumstances obviously if she works
that the other is fine but if it came
down to where I was in a position where
she wouldn't need to work
and especially I think
I I think by Nature like I want to be
the woman that's more nurturing so you
know that early stages before the kids
start to go to school
I'll take one for the team you know you
gotta stay at home especially if I can
provide that life for us you know so
that's why I expected to give after that
you know we're open to talks
but in that period
gotta playable man you know if it's the
best thing for the family yeah
did you answer what you would give up
for the right guy I don't remember no
not really okay because I was thinking
about it then it was kind of like um
I don't know I probably
wouldn't give up anything nothing no
okay relationships require stuff no I
haven't I I have a fiance obviously and
I love him but the I think the the only
reason probably is coming from that that
is he's very he he wants me the way I
want I am I mean
um I think I love dancing so he doesn't
me going to there because I do a bit of
a TV personality in Persian channels so
I do a lot of dancing I do a lot of you
know cameras I do like Persian Latino so
I mix both I will I will do a bit of a
dance here and so because because I do
whatever I always wanted to do right now
and he's very happy with the way I am
even though I'm most of the time just
you know I'm very like outgoing and
stuff and spending a lot of time out
because of the camera and videos and my
friends
um and he's always involved and he's
loving the fact that I'm very outgoing
and social so he doesn't say oh I don't
like that don't do that don't do this so
I think maybe lets you do whatever you
want so probably if he tells me don't
dance I wouldn't give up because I'm I'm
so pretty what if he told you delete
social media
social media for social media because I
have a big platform on Instagram and I
really worked hard for it you make any
Revenue any type of money do you get
paid from social media no but I have a
big amazing family it's like you know
you're having when you build up
exactly sorry you can call it firm in a
FaceTime your family oh I talk about my
family in Iran I I called Instagram my
family as well because I I kind of like
hold on better than your real family
like your fiance no I just don't
understand why anybody wants me to
delete my Instagram in case you can see
them in real life yeah well it's easy
come come
come
two days ago uh Justin Waller he's like
a YouTuber and this guy has married
women
um constantly trying to sleep with him
on social media all the time like
literally like he's shown me like videos
pictures of girls like saying come over
and like he'll show me pictures of their
families right yeah and he doesn't do it
because he's he's not that type of guy
yeah you know yeah but but
it's like if a guy just wants to avoid
that headache yeah of you you know
potentially doing something like you
wouldn't understand that if a lot of um
divorces like come from social media
that's true because my sister had you
know lots of argue with his with her
husband because of social media but now
thinking about it if obviously he wants
me to delete Instagram otherwise he's
not going to be with me because I I
really love him and he's he's amazing so
probably I would but I think I'm going
to be depressed
is he is he Iranian no he's English okay
okay
I don't know it explains a lot
when you have that women we don't have
that sort of things in your life you
don't really think about it but now
because we're discussing it it's
actually good for me because when you
discuss it I get into myself and
thinking if one the dial want me to
delete my Instagram because we never had
that conversation and I never thought
about it but now you're asking me and
I'm thinking about it probably I would
but I can ask you would you like give
would you give up just pearly things for
the right shoes oh yeah easily yeah to I
mean to be honest I would I would really
want to get my
yeah I mean to be honest I don't think
the show is conducive like what am I
going to do this when I have kids no
[Music]
I mean if it was genuinely causing a
problem in my marriage like I would no I
mean it's social media you know what I
mean that's what I was gonna say I don't
know sorry yeah go ahead I was gonna say
I don't understand why social media has
such a grip on people nowaday like it
hasn't been around for that long it's
only what 9 10 imagine saying that 10
year old controls your life and it isn't
your child that is crazy to me like yeah
fair enough I'll go on social media most
days when you actually really think
about what is it that you're doing
unless like your full-time content
creator now or like some form of
celebrity where you need to have that
level of Engagement to my mind now if
you just only going like this on with
your thing with your thumb scrolling on
a glass that's why wasting your time no
I I wouldn't if I was like that like
just scrolling in you know waste wasting
my time I wouldn't even care if I want
to delete my Instagram to be honest if
your man asked for it you're gonna
delete it didn't you yeah 100 yeah what
about girls trips would you give up
girls trips 100
10 nights yes but I love my grocery
actually tonight when I go home I'm
gonna
I'm gonna ask him if if there's one
thing he wants me to give up on what
would it be I don't know I should ask
him
what if he came back and said now that
you asked yeah
and this
oh well no it's actually interesting you
make me kind of like aware of what about
plastic surgery would you get plastic
surgery for a guy if if like I I did my
boob job because after I had Neda I just
lost the fat because I lost weight and I
did it for myself because I hated it and
I wanted to do it but um if I had to do
it because of
him
no not really no I'm scared of plastic
surgeries I mean I did this 10 years ago
but now I'm getting older I'm scared of
that sort of thing okay
um did you say what you would give up
for a guy you know what this actually
this conversation made me think when I
was younger we actually we women we do
that we do give up things we why do we
dress a certain way
to for men to look at us and I think you
know I think there was times when I was
too conscious of I wanna be a certain
way so I can get the attention from men
but no that's not the case anymore
that's why I can speak freely about this
uh if I would get plastic surgery no
giving up things like my social media my
career yes
but when it comes to I don't know this
is it's just
as well because I now I'm thinking when
it was about 2025 and I had a boyfriend
and I fell in love with him and to be
honest I would have done anything but
not now were you more in love then
probably
okay so so it sounds like four
the like the right guy you would give up
more yeah
I mean I don't know is it a is it age or
am I wrong is it the age
gotta be the right guy
only the guy it should be your age as
well yeah because the opposite it was I
don't know maybe like I was raised by a
feminist mom and he was like don't get
married don't have kids
no but she's very happy she's got
granddaughter I'm the only one out of
her four kids who's giving her a
grandchild could it be because when you
get older when you get more experience
experience and you get more confident
you kind of feel like why do I have to
do that maybe because maybe because you
don't love you that much if I did have
that much I don't call it I don't I
don't think it's love only no I don't
think I should do something because I
should do my boob job because I love him
and he wants me to do it I don't call it
love if he would really truly love me he
would love me the way I look yeah that's
gonna be my ideal man like I've got a
second there you know this does not want
me to have a I just don't like all that
any of that stuff anyway but so I think
I call it my um I'm I'm more mature
in terms of making decisions rather than
just because someone maybe I would have
I I have maybe I would have tell him
wait blessing I have to give a statement
um okay this camera is Michael here
can you see if he'll take the show for
like while I go do it I have to give a
police statement I guess for the lady
called the police oh I'm so sorry bro
serious yeah
guys we're gonna get King Richie's to
take over the show yes
um ridiculous
seriously yeah I guess she couldn't just
a lot of Mercy are you sure it's not a
crackhead in a police Outfield
[Music]
yeah I was right when I told her calm
down when she spoke to me in a certain
time I I saw her and it was it was
getting a bit spicier
drunk yeah I just said calm down and she
went no no I'm just saying but the
environment was just real spicy
she just
yeah she went off and then she was
trying to say that I said that domestic
abuse was okay I didn't even I don't
know where she got these these ideas
and going off of random tangents as well
and just not even just listen so how
tall are you before I go I wanted to
hear so you said you had a feminist
mother when did you because you seem
actually pretty based
like so yeah so I'm like you know you
don't scream like feminism to me I'm so
sorry um rebelled against my Mom finally
you know I well yeah I was born 1980. so
I grew up in the 90s and yeah moving
from Iran
um to Sweden it was my mom was like
woohoo Freedom do what you want was your
mom a single mother
um yeah they split up when I was 12.
okay divorced my dad and had two jobs
two three jobs and you know really tried
to provide for us really good Mom
amazing I love her but she really um I
said to her my only complaint was like
You Raised Me based on ideologies that
you had not you know I never really got
you it was more
what you believed in about you know
being a feminist being an atheist and
um
so yeah and I um
yeah I'm definitely not a feminist
so I'm curious do you did your mom ever
get remarried no she was with someone
for like 20 years but not she didn't get
remarried oh okay so it's yeah I was
just wondering if she had a better
outcome or not I've always wondered
about that when sorry oh my goodness now
and that's not direct to you personally
but because I grew up single parent home
but I've always wondered where they told
it they were out there working two three
jobs yeah I'll sing them up and then
telling her daughter to go out and do
the same I just I don't understand how
okay
I mean I've worked two three jobs before
yes I have to go give a police statement
so um we'll miss you I have to go give a
police statement so I'm gonna let you
out for a second oh wow okay yeah this
is
um this is King Rich's he's um he's um
one of the most talented hello
um um he he has a show anyways
we're talking about what would you give
up for the right guy oh that works
wow what's going on people
so so where did where am I picking up
like what was the current conversation
mandano was saying about
um how her mother raised her base on
ideologies and she never really got her
but then we was talking just lately
right here this young lady was talking
about her experiences with her mother
yeah as a feminist so oh your mom was a
feminist yes and she tried to install
that programming into you she did did
you accept it or reject it well I dab
and along with them growing up like I
was saying I was you know born 1980 and
then being a teenager in the 90s Madonna
and you know all of that Material Girl
yeah the material world yeah um yeah
when along with that and then you know
someone mentioned Neo independent woman
you know the music is huge yeah Carmen
mentioned that had a huge impact and uh
yeah I thought that was the the the
right way so I worked hard I mean
literally in my 20s I worked like 78
hours a week I loved my job absolutely
loved it
um and then
I did settle down with a guy but I
didn't get married because that wasn't a
value like my mom was like don't worry
about getting married do I have kids
just live your life maybe not so you saw
what your mom was like yeah just go out
there get money and live your movie yeah
so like how do you feel about that now
um
do you feel like actually miles stood
you in the wrong direction
um
you can be real man she's man she's not
here
no I love my mom and you know she's a
you can love your mom but your mom still
can be wrong you know yeah absolutely
and I do tell her that every day bless
her no if you had your time again would
you no I would um
I would get married I would have gotten
married
um
yeah stayed married and stayed married
would you have marriage I was with my
daughter's dad for about 12 years
[Music]
um do you think he should have been your
husband
you know like in the beginning like when
he mentioned marriage I was I don't want
to get married forget that like
yeah and um I never really understood
like the the value in getting married
but I think like actually giving your
word giving your word that you are going
to stick with this person
I think that will make a bigger
difference in actually making it work do
you think do you would you agree that a
lot of times a lot of older women give
younger women bad advice 100
. would you not think about that
100 makes that's what makes the market
kicked out basically that's what I was
saying to her I'm like but why she's the
oldest one inmate yeah I think it just
depends on like you said the programming
what programming did that older woman
received what kind of software exactly
so if you if you've got the corrupt if
you've got the malware malware you know
like that if you get if you come from a
two-parent household then you're more
likely to and still get you should come
you should a two parent household should
come from you because you came from a
two-part household but if you come from
a single parent household and it's the
mum saying yeah well I would had to work
two free jobs so I don't maybe they say
they don't want that for her but for
their child yeah but but the reason is
that that men are bad in it like you
can't find a good man basically I'm like
my dad wasn't the best I loved him like
to me he did his best but as a husband
and how he
treated my mom in certain ways but I
also you know think a lot of women don't
take responsibility for
their part they don't see the
psychological abuse they just don't see
it I constantly making a man wrong like
the way
women can make a man feel like is
women don't really see that so yeah
what do you think about you know
feminism what do you think about it
though I think it's you should
set us back like way back and the way
that
oh don't get me started
way back I think what I what I noticed
in like when I really look at like the
society and the media especially like if
you notice a lot of me like kind of
it kind of installed that programming as
well because like for instance when you
watch like a lot even cartoons you might
watch The Simpsons or Family Guy the dad
is always like an idiot he's always like
a fumbling and the mum has to be the one
controlled one that's level-headed where
the where the dad is just like an idiot
and you know it's subtle but it it's
actually quite significant because
everybody watches The Simpsons everyone
watches and it's just like yeah I think
that Society um the media it really
pushes for like you know men are
incapable women have to take the the
reins of everything can like girl power
kind of thing what do you not think
about it what's the consequences of it
was the consequences of it men are
emasculated yeah men are masculated
women not women are not to say women
shouldn't feel like you know they can
make decisions yeah but at the end of
the day most women will want a man that
is a leader a man that is competent a
man that is confident the man that you
know she can rely on and look to you
know in times of need where they don't
want to they don't want to couple up
with Homer Simpson they don't want to
couple up with Peter Griffin
I was saying that earlier sorry how do
you think we can change the situation I
think it's every man's Duty personally
to be the best version of himself I
think that every man should uh strive to
get financial power physical power you
know be you know in best physical shape
he can yeah mental power he cannot
afford to be ignorant you just can't bro
like and as women we have to empower
those men because I I just talk to women
a lot and I'm like you talk so much
about men how do you expect to meet a
nice man The Law of Attraction you know
and um the other thing is
um
sorry I
saw power coming in I lost my um
you've got Starstruck yeah
especially because she called me bass
thank you thank you thank you it was a
quick statement
okay
this is what I was gonna say how is how
we how what we do about it let's get
shut down
let's get a round of applause thank you
for King riches yeah
[Applause]
and you're the one she was uh telling
you why you're not smiling do you
remember that's why he wasn't she was so
desperate for a long time
what were you guys talking about
um we were saying like how so you know
the situational with feminism
demasculated like a guy was saying so
like what do we do about that and I'm
like you're shutting down people like
that like like exactly like
this is what has got to stop like women
talking about men is going on and
on and on and I just shut it down as
much as I can and yeah sometimes I do
get into arguments with my girlfriends
but so what did you did your mom do that
to you because you said you said your
mom was a feminist that you talk
about me yeah yeah I I yeah I shut her
down immediately when was your like red
pill moment that switched is that no
because I I'd imagine at some point like
I mean if she was talking like this when
you were a kid you kind of believe what
your parents say for a while yeah yeah
absolutely but um it was in my
relationship
um when I was having arguments with my
ex-partner it was like I could just
afterwards I was like those were not my
opinions it's like I can hear my mom's
voice in my head but like I said it got
to a point where it kind of got a bit
too late to to be able to like save that
relationship it just got to a point it
could have gotten abusive from both
sides
um but yeah that it was it was
not that long ago
um and one of the questions I was going
to ask you like what what would you do
now to like compete for a guy compete
yeah I mean it's always that love is a
competition you don't think
what would I do to compete
that's a good question what does that
mean yeah yeah like okay
would you agree that most women go for
the same types of guys
yeah in in terms of there's a list of
things that women want and there's only
a small percentage of men that fit that
that have good enough jobs that are good
enough looking that are tall enough
there's not enough men that we want to
go around there's enough men to go
around but not that that women I would
um
I am starting to learn to listen
to the man and shut my mouth a bit more
finding it difficult I'm not succeeding
every time so but that's yeah that's
what I would really take on is is to be
a lot more feminine now because I did
take on being a masculine and
you're an athlete though
and my GP things like my testosterone is
high so no I think it's a thing I can
like tell when women play sports like
from a young age I don't know what it is
but it's like I can because you're an
athlete no no I it's me too but I'm like
I think I've heard it imbalances or
hormones it does that's what my my
doctor was saying well all the sports
you're doing and all this is not helping
really what did he say I'm so curious
that's what he said he goes that my test
it's hard and he said and I was doing
like kickboxing at some point he was
like well that's not gonna help you be
feminine why don't you start dancing
I actually really yes thank you I really
want to start dancing yeah and um yes I
will get in touch with you about that
let's do it because my coordination when
it comes to dancing with this crap if
you play football you already you must
have yeah
I'm in the same way
I'm like what are they doing like I
can't do like what's the coordination is
so different than sport I know exactly
what you're talking about
I mean I wasn't soccer I couldn't do the
feet we call it football here I'm sorry
I can't soccer to me it's okay yes so uh
yeah I would uh compete in yeah keeping
myself fit I'm in my 40s now so I can't
afford to let myself go
um yeah keep myself fit and really like
being more submissive and feminine
because
um yeah do you think you could be in the
top one percent of listeners to keep the
man that you're saying yeah let's go for
that mate do you have you ever like
sought out to learn certain skills um
for a guy
so like cooking cleaning I don't know my
ex taught me how to cook okay and cheese
yeah have you ever thought about
reconciling could you ever
um no I don't
I is he still single
it might be now I don't want to talk
about his business okay okay yeah but um
no I think of it past that we get on we
get on but
um
I can't get into like the personal stuff
but they're they're um
no there are certain differences that
uh
I can't it's not by choice there are
certain things that just can't okay what
about the guys have you ever sought out
to learn a certain skill to get women
not really no the women always just came
to you I think just before you fall in
place
what with me I mean for me women fall in
place so don't need to
you know really learn anything yeah we
all right look how tall you are you're
all right
yeah you're nice dunking on man when I
was like late teens early 20s now it's
like that cool like I need to make sure
I've got a job so I have a little bit of
money so I can say okay let's go to the
cinema or something I need to I was
working out a lot more
because it's like I could walk no gold I
want no fat guy I'm already short so
like let me try and work on those loads
of things I try to work on to be
but there's loads of things I try to
work on to try and be more appealing
because I I didn't I feel like for me
personally it was a lot more to do with
my self-image where I didn't view myself
as the most attractive so yeah maybe
that came across to the women that I was
talking to at the time
um whereas now
I have a lot more self-confidence so
like I can engage in conversation more
and be more uh successful in just having
General conversations where I wasn't at
that point and I thought if I did these
things I would be more successful when
it really just should have worked on
myself did you actively like study how
to talk to women how to approach women
no no none of that stuff I don't know if
you're a pickup guy no no but I thought
if well if I have the because I was
already fighting with like telling jokes
and stuff like that but it was just like
I felt like if I had the look if I had
the if I had a Blackberry if I had like
the right clothes if I made sure I
always had a haircut yeah like other
little things I thought I could make it
work so yeah
I think
um that I don't think there's anything
wrong with that it's all about
self-improvement at the end of the day
and um yes this worked for my benefit
man it's maybe on each side of myself I
didn't know I had you know book a room
confident happy within my myself I'm not
the I I don't look the ideal way I want
to look by working towards it and whilst
I'm working towards it I just believe
I'm that guy man that's it you know I
think that's what the
the main thing is just confidence yeah
man for men in in general from your
confidence it it doesn't matter because
even today we all came in didn't know
each other was all sat down just talking
and everyone was able to get along
I'm shy
I think before we came in yeah as soon
as that camera went on work yeah but I
knew I knew even before that she was um
she never really listened to anyone she
was just very much me me just talked
about herself and that's supposed to be
why she's in a situation Yeah by herself
well this is coming upstairs
everybody in the room oh okay
oh my God what about these people that
want to sneeze you don't want to talk
about this or not
I talked to the face I guess you could
say no see I don't know
I don't I don't really deal with the
police yeah I don't
think I've ever this would have been
different America
no I mean don't come but I actually
think they come out
no actually they came pretty fast today
everyone always says here that they
don't come fast this is pretty quick let
me call them
has this happened on the show before no
I mean I've kicked people I think I've
kicked what either two or three people
off but the police you know the police
yeah yeah that's the this is the first I
should have called the police wow though
for the security guard doing his job
brother when I tell you at the start
there was a energy in a Vibe and I was
like this show won't be interested
that's what I knew I didn't know it was
going to get to this level but it's
crazy you know
get a little crazy sometimes crazy I
have a video for us to react to but I
don't know what
wait I shouldn't wait to react to the
video yeah
I would like to learn how to bake that
is something I would like to Bicycle I
can I can teach you how to make cookies
from scratch yeah
seriously yeah
give back my feedback that's like I'm
not saying I can bake everything but I
do make good cookies I do that's okay I
can't even make cookies chocolate chip
we could do a wife School episode or I
teach something
for a change I usually I usually am the
one being taught yeah you can teach me
that'll be cool I'm I'm curious um guys
has dating changed um you're in your you
said you're almost 40. no I am in my 40s
you look younger than me thank you so
much
42 or you're 42. what is the difference
between dating in your 40s than in your
30s and in your 20s I don't really date
you don't date it's too busy playing
football
oh okay
one at a time it's live baby
line up and give you statements okay
talk to everyone outside
yeah yeah no so what are they doing
but they can come inside yeah just
overcome obviously pull up a chair we've
got to spare mics
another ladies like men in Men in
uniforms
not those uniforms
yeah I strike a good image in my my
Smith's my Smith Blues
this is ruin it wow wow what's going on
what what's happening what's going on
why
the Super Chat supposed to be going
crazy trust me yeah I'll read super
chats that's a good idea I was trying to
figure out what to do right now showing
some love out there so guys um the
police are here
um I guess they're taking some what
the the feds yeah
oh okay
um
from Scotland yeah to Pearl's yard Trust
yeah so guys Sun Super Chat and it's
very nice you guys to send super chats
how how sweet of you all right moral for
all all you got to do is play the video
back
see don't I know I should just send them
the link see dumbledorff um IG was
engineered to feed women's addiction to
attention and made them worth one
trillion but now the damage is done to
women it's showing it's lost lost half
of its value it's made women attention
holics your drunkards um Anthony Baker
here's ten dollars for security
um the clue Channel this one's for
security Luke casley um shout out to uh
Pearl's security detail
um a Scott and Bradley men only argue
with the women that they love if they
don't love them
um they say screw it not worth it a
scout and Bradley Pearl please explain
the wall to them D um this is a request
to mute her mic please uh well we did do
one more than that
uh Manny f
um
are you good guy
um do you agree that if a woman chooses
to become anorexic it's okay because she
chooses that lifestyle um DAV NX I'm
1701. Pearl why did you invite that
woman
um Sinnerman final thought compromising
between the couple isn't weak it's when
women forget about the compromise
because they're used to availability and
options to get the attention of
belittling men moral for all I need um
Jay oh wait I read that one already or
that's from last show Let me refresh it
real quick thank you guys for the super
chats I really appreciate it you know
um
all right I think we're done security
goes hard out here
professional what stole War professional
yeah yeah yeah might handle that well
yeah
okay
um
are they taking statements from Helen
now oh okay so then what are they gonna
do us all one by one
if you told them
oh
themselves
okay so they don't have to take all of
our statements
I mean I don't know how do you deal with
the police here
yeah okay you just you tell me I don't I
don't know how to deal with the police
here
send them the video actually okay well
I'm actually gonna
um so dating between your 40s and your
20s any different
like I said I don't really date so you
don't really do I don't I mean um split
up with my ex what two years ago focus
on my daughter
and
um
I get approached by a lot of younger
younger guys
thank you it's and it's not it's not my
cup of tea
um
I don't like online dating I've never
done online dating have you found it's
harder to date men your own age when
you're older
I haven't really tried
maybe I should try
have you actually put yourself out in
the market or not
on the market
I would love to I would love to be in a
relationship so what's what's stopping
you
um
I need to work on myself like I said I I
don't know if I could put a man through
what I already put a man through but
because in my head it's like how would
you get better at listening wouldn't you
have to be with a man to practice
listening uh yes
um
which is okay but I'm just I'm just
wondering how you would get there
um
yes Paul this is getting very personal
um yes I would have to put myself in
that situation but who knows maybe I
know a guy you know
what I don't want to say volunteers for
statements no no do they they got my
statement
I mean I can give okay all right I'm
gonna go give a statement I guess chat
amongst yourselves
so yeah so as Paul was saying now yeah
um wouldn't you have to practice maybe
if you had like a a male friend that
could be your bestie and you just
practice listening to his trials and
tribulations
and then you'll know okay there is a guy
that I like okay yeah it's coming out
and I keep messing up with him so how so
like what do you mean by messing up like
I said like I have my ways
um like does he say like oh how are you
doing and you're like the picture okay
no no no I'm definitely not like that I
just um
you need to listen to him yeah like my
reactions sometimes and
um he just doesn't have it which is what
I really like about him that he doesn't
like pop with my shirt you're strong are
you bossy tough do are you trying to say
you're a bossy and you're trying not to
no it's not even that I'm oh gosh
do you are you one of those women where
because of the way that you are you want
someone to be able to be like
no Mandana don't do that at all don't
talk to me I have a certain tone
and the way I can just react with that
thinking you need to put you need to put
you in your place that's what you like
yeah that's what you want hmm
yeah and that's okay that's okay that
was absolutely okay and um that's not a
bad thing and I do really like him and I
think I've just messed up one too many
times so he's would you still talk yeah
he's fed up if you see me in my place if
you still talk to him I'm sure God give
me some advice for sure no I was just
thinking you're saying you you think
that you've messed up one too many times
but you still talk to him if if I to my
mind if he was really wasn't interested
he wouldn't talk to you anymore okay so
I agree with you yeah yeah I'm sure if
he's still talking to you even do you
think you messed up a lot of times
somebody is very interested maybe he
wants to go to prep tomorrow but
um
talk about it
but no but he okay so yes he's somebody
that I could practice with being more
feminine or whatever but he's not
somebody who wants to be in a
relationship he wants to commit so it
wouldn't be the right person for me
okay
but maybe things could change well we
could live in Hope yeah he could never
know but it's but it's um do you live in
Hope or do you just take someone's word
for it when they say what they want or
what they don't want
so they got it out of me what happened
oh keep me in the now
also the police
I just asked the questions the police
left that's great yeah yeah
um
oh sorry okay look what the police yeah
shout out to the London Police
Department for doing a great job yeah
um is he talking about your ex no it's
so different there's a different guy
it's someone that she likes because she
was saying about practicing to listen to
be the type of woman that a top 20 or
whatever percentage of men would go for
and I was saying oh soon like you're
saying about
um having to be with a man in order to
practice those things she said that she
has a friend that she likes and that she
does do those things with but she feels
like she's messed up too many times but
I said do you still speak to him she
said yes so I was saying in response to
that if you still speak to him that it's
highly unlikely to my mind that you have
messed up too many times because you
still speak to him so you never know but
then she then rebutted that by saying
that he has said that she he doesn't
want to be in a relationship uh so but
they're now saying that you never know
what do you suggest because yeah so he
basically thinks women are a headache he
doesn't want the headache and he's kind
of my age one year younger than me and
um
so yeah and basically what I've done is
show him that yes we are a headache have
have you have you ever been in a
situation where a guy didn't want to
date you and then wanted to date you
me personally that's never happened
if it was a no agility I never turned it
into a yes
well this is the thing we started off
casual so I thought after my ex yes I'm
single like after 12 years
you know like just listening to my
friends yeah have fun whatever so that's
how we started but
um the new one I mean as women we always
have yeah yeah and you know yeah yeah
totally and then I caught feelings but
he's really like I mean you're supposed
to you're a woman like that but he's
also like really nice and treated and
treated me nice and whatever and then I
showed my messed up side and he put me
in my place and cheese I think um maybe
that's why you're interested because he
put you in the right place 100 because
he is yeah
is that toxic
yeah so we question
um when is the when's the last time you
saw him
last night
I did see him today at the gym oh okay
okay so you're still seeing him
it's okay if he watches this okay you're
not it's not being decision no I know
you're not do you think you're the only
girl like come on I know but I I'm like
I wasn't prepared to talk about it
publicly but hey so yeah so question um
when did he how long ago did he tell you
that he wasn't looking for anything from
the beginning we were both kind of like
yeah but I'm not looking for a
relationship and did you tell him your
feelings changed
uh
uh kinda yes not to the extent
that I am feeling feelings but yeah
pretty much how long have you been
um do you love him
how long have you been how long is this
situationship been taking place I don't
know I'm not one of those one minute
I'll have to I know you know this one
now six months right now
tell him you love him I love him yeah
well then you know
okay okay all right confessions
she's getting excited
I think it's sweet I think it's cute it
is nice because this reaction to my mind
this reaction is direction that should
come from genuine feeling yeah yes no
ladies yeah yeah I mean I do listen I do
really like him and I have uh
yeah I I do have feelings for him and
but but yeah it's the rejection thing
it's like he's always told me that
yeah
I'm a big believer in like going after
what you want yeah and I feel like if
you want to go after it and if that's
what I coach people right now I'm in
that situation but and so if you're not
what he wants what he wants figure out
why see if you can fix it and if it's
not something that can be fixed if you
want to change it then you move on okay
but yeah yeah right I don't know I'm I'm
just shooting your Curry I'm just a
shooter I'm like a shooter shoot you
know
[Music]
um
yeah I am usually and I I've not been in
this situation I feel like in you know
I've been in three or four serious
relationships
um and I feel like I was was just chosen
I've not like chosen the guy I want to
be with and then going through this
do you feel like it would have been
better if you had been the Chooser
instead of the choose E Yeah like yeah
like sometimes I think I just kind of
gave it not give it I definitely loved
my ex like attracted to him loved him
all of that but it was yeah it was more
like
him
making the effort and I was oh okay
so whereas now it's the other way around
and I'm I I don't quite know what to do
but he's never had to be in you've never
been in that space I've never been in
this space for somebody to tell me like
he wants me he he thought I was amazing
was really excited about it and then I
just showed this side and he was a bit
like whoa
um so it just wanted him right that
women are a headache and it's gonna get
what do you what'd you do
sorry what do you do
um it's okay
I got jealous one time and I
I did raise my voice and I shouted at
him and what made you jealous
it's okay I promise you I promise you
Instagram it's nothing I haven't heard
before I promise you I know we promise
you it's not live I'm talking about yes
cut this bit out yeah
um
oh man
I'm trying to see if I can edit this
situation
I just saw him with female friends in a
situation he wasn't doing anything wrong
he really wasn't you just didn't like it
I just didn't like it you got in your
feelings yeah I just didn't like it and
acted how a man would that's what I'm
saying like my masculine energy like
football coming back to haunt you yeah
you're thinking the only girl that acted
jealous over a female friend I don't
want to be like it happens you're human
yeah
his point was even like until you raised
your voice you like screamed to him I
didn't scream but I did I did raise my
voice so then he was like women are a
headache yeah and then he was like well
if I then reacts to your reaction and
then it's not going to be was it in
front of her no it wasn't no no it was
like two days later oh okay this really
happens okay so how long ago was this
this was like in the beginning that was
like the first time so after you know
but did you do it again did it repeat or
no no not not like that and then there
were times also like he just seems to
have a lot of female friends and I'm
like you're trying to get me jealous are
you trying to get a reaction I will buy
you always tell me maybe maybe he was a
bit of a player
um I mean remember we usually like men
that are sleeping with other girls
I mean just I mean we usually do just
from a numbers standpoint
yeah is he is he successful I thought
that he's got a good job okay so yeah
it's actually makes high values
you're right I actually feel more you
know I feel like oh he's so attractive
when I feel like he's talking to girls
and you know yeah I feel jealous and it
actually makes me yeah it's a good thing
yeah
it makes you say it makes you like him
more when he's talking to other girls
yeah it's value to it yeah yeah no I
mean it's called pre-selection I don't
know what it is no it's it's called it's
called um pre-selection so basically in
history
um 17 women reproduced for every one man
so like most the most men that
reproduced had multiple women and it was
because like if I saw that he um married
you or had a kid with you and you I
would know he took care of you too so he
could take care of you too yeah it's
interesting that is that makes sense
[Music]
um I don't know I think I mean worst
case scenario he just rejects you and
then you can move on yeah yeah you know
at least you know but if you're saying
that all of this happened early on and
you saw him today
like I don't know it does give me like
he has given me chances he's like it's
my fault because I keep like giving any
more chances I need to work on my tone
and not be so like aggressive
energetically masculine so you have your
homework you just do it and then you
should present it to him get your a star
okay
submissive I did say say that to him and
the other day he said to me about your
high maintenance was I don't know if
there's anyone
yeah but guys it's kind of like we don't
want to train guys to be a good man you
know I know it's like just like grow up
but I guess it was probably hard for you
because it wasn't like you had that
example at home because you you really
expect like a feminist yeah are there
are you around other like wives
ever like like feminine women because
how else would you learn where are they
um I'm Church you go to church at all
religious no
um I read the Bible and the Quran well I
mean
so what would you guys recommend to meet
married people
I do this I do I do actually I do have
friends that are married and ladies
maybe I should speak to them more yeah
are they feminine
um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
actually recently like started um seen
one of my friends again that I wasn't
talking to for a while and I was at her
house and
um and her husband was coming home from
work and then um She Was preparing like
the food like he called so that she
prepared it so just as he walks in it's
ready it's ready and I was like oh I
love that she's like but you see this is
what it's like being married to a Greek
man like you have to get the food you
know ready on tap and I said well you
want the bills paid on time she was like
yeah that's true so so yeah
um yeah I'm gonna hang out more with my
marriage I wouldn't say it's a Greek men
thing like if I had the dinner ready as
I walked in the door I'm not gonna be
like oh what's that that's the sweet
spot right there thanks yeah that's
what's expected like she like that has
got to be like you know he called like
I'm gonna be there in five minutes like
make sure it's but then obviously that
that's Testament to their communication
and that you know yeah no really great
and they've got two beautiful kids and
yeah they've got good marriage it's
beautiful beautiful thing yeah okay I
think I'm ready to show you guys the
video
[Music]
um
King you want to show it
can you see oh boy yeah yeah okay you
can play it
when I talk about those men's Peak
sexual market value it's right around 36
37 38 years old right there and the
reason for that is because women have
different criteria for what they find
arousing and attractive so when a guy is
right around 35 36 37 that's the years
in which he has the most potential to
have what makes him the most attractive
to women that's that's how I judge that
that's how I I put that out there now
the thing is is that it takes longer for
men to get there it takes longer for men
to mature into that into there yes it
does and it's not because it's not
because
[Music]
it's because it takes longer because men
must become and women just are I was
just going to say you used that quote
the other day I was like oh what the
hell does that mean well because women
women are and men must become what does
that mean okay and I'm not so because
like Adam even said like I was crazy
partying when I was younger and I I feel
like I've even dated guys now who are
like no I like your age that you're
older I can't deal with a 21 year old
girl they're trying to work you no
they're not no no she does have a point
like
there are 21 22 23 year olds running
around where it's like yeah they're hot
no doubt yeah but a lot of guys don't
want to I'm not trying to ask about how
you're you know how was class today baby
like I need someone who at least has
some substance of what's going on so for
me 25 to like 30 scores but once again
were you as were you in your most Peak
potential when you were in your 20s or
when you hit 30 or 40. now how much
money do you have
um
35 to basically now I feel like I'm in
Prague you have everyone's on their own
Journey so like yeah certain people can
hit numbers earlier or for me personally
like I thought for sure I was gonna be
married and have a family but now I'm so
grateful that I didn't and have these
other projects and passions that I've
established on my own so and on this
note you're from Miami South Beach no
where are you from no I'm originally
Southern California okay Miami
something I'm from up North I'm from
Pennsylvania the north is so different
every place is different yeah when I
left here people said why would you
leave Miami and my answer it was
difficult to describe but I said my soul
was dying
because I felt that way in L.A oh my God
yes you're just you're evaluated so
critically and and then too it's kind of
fun when you like reach the top of
everyone's standards and you're like
okay you bye it's just it's not
interesting that's what I realized when
I when I went back I saw it was a
magazine ad for a yoga and I was like oh
my God that's my body I was perfect but
it's never enough because there's a
million other people and it's never
enough
and so where I am right now I know I'm
kind of getting hit as if I am supposed
to take a partner
I don't want it I have so much
calm I have like I have such a nice life
and I didn't have that nice life when
all of this headache was going on
when's your like birthday
like what's your astrology sign oh cool
I'm so happy you asked yeah it's uh I'm
December 29th so you're a Capricorn as
well I'm a Capricorn
we are like very
loyal hard workers Rebecca you
fascinating here's my question for you
yes how many of your best friends best
friends are married with kids
I don't have a lot of best friends but I
know everybody who all your friends from
high school college graduate school when
I went back up there if there's a
hundred of them how many of them are
married with kids from graduate school
they're mostly from other countries in
general but she doesn't compare herself
that's not my point but that's what I
mean it's not a comparison
number no I see them and they've they've
grown and they have other lives and
they've they have husbands and this just
isn't my life what percentage I think a
lot of them do so 90 plus percent I
guess okay well I'm just saying all my
best friends and I have dozens and I
grew up in Miami all my friends
like five percent I'm still hanging with
we're going out like five percent
meaning the other 95 are married with
kids so you're the anomaly this is all
I'm trying to say is that you're
successful beautiful and I don't need no
man I got my own thing because because
you're it's not it I don't need no man
it's I have a very happy peaceful life I
love what I do I get better at what I do
every day and if there's somebody who
can enhance my happiness I'm very happy
your career is your baby I would say
career it's um more of a call her
passion
absolutely
I
um agree with what you were saying just
because a lot of my friends are mostly
in couples and
I do think about like okay they're gonna
have babies soon and like I don't want
to be the single friend forever you
won't be Victoria you're going to be
great thank you
uh what did you guys think of that clip
I wouldn't say she's I think what a guy
was saying
like about men becoming like I can
relate to that based on what I was
saying before but oh yeah the clothes
and the hair and that's
me becoming I had to go through that in
order to be who I am now
um so I can relate to that
I think it was I think what did you
think of the women in the clip
I feel like the woman the older woman if
I can say that um
she seemed to remind me of um the other
lady but um it's a little bit scattered
like he's asking direct questions and
she can't give an answer and then she's
saying that her career isn't her career
so call him but if that's what you do in
then that's what you do it's your career
but then I don't know it it just seems
like she wasn't
really show up herself she I feel like
she's happy in what she's doing but like
she said when she was when she thought
she looked perfect she wanted more but I
still feel like she she came across like
to me that she still wanted more anyway
even though she might not be outwardly
saying that
I think she was delusional she's just
falling herself those women it's like
they're just so resigned because she
said my life is so peaceful now like
it's not possible to have a peaceful
life with a man
so I think women like that are just so
resigned that it can't be possible why
why do you think she's like that
um programming I think people
uh look I live in my own bubble because
I don't like being too
um too much exposed to all this
information
people are just told how they should
think I think
um I I had um two friends they're older
than me and um one of them was a guy and
one of them was a lady who
um so the guy was saying
um I don't have time I'm my business is
my baby and after after a while that
we've been hanging out and I realized
actually he loves to have a partner or a
wife but he's got so many attitudes that
I don't think he can keep anyone and I
think sometimes they know that they have
so many
um I don't know if there's the right way
to say it they have so many issues that
they can't
hold on to a relationship and they have
so many I don't want to call it failure
but they had so many unsuccessful
relationships that when it comes to the
public they decide to say oh I'm I'm my
business is my baby I'm very happy but
generally they're not really happy they
just feel like it's going to be it's a
cope yeah yeah I agree and they don't
want to work on them it's the men or the
women this one the one it's a guy do you
do you see that women
um older single women are generally
happy being older and single no no no no
I don't mind I mean I don't know
I think because I have a daughter so I'm
kind of like I think if I I didn't have
a daughter I probably will be like
desperate to have a relationship and get
married and I definitely would say that
but if you are in a relationship so
you're not single so how would you know
how no that's why I I'm kind of like
thinking that's why it's difficult
you're right because when you you're in
a you know
um
and you felt lonely like and you've got
your daughter and she's living her own
life she's 16 like you said right now
yeah so it's difficult for me to you're
right to making you know the state do
you think if you didn't have a daughter
that you would be lonely
no
do you think you'd be perfectly
fulfilled no I I wanted to be in
relationships no I'm saying like if you
didn't have a relationship or a daughter
do you think you would be lonely
no not now
I feel quite fulfilled with my uh
partner and my no but I'm sorry maybe I
don't get I'm saying if you didn't have
a partner like if you have no partner
and no daughter
no partner no daughter yeah
but do you know any women in that
position especially because all my
friends they're all like married having
two three kids and literally all of them
are married and having kids probably I
would feel lonely yeah
were there any things you did to um you
said you're a trainer have you always
been in shape or did you like lose
weight
I I always been in shape but obviously
when I got pregnant like I you know
overweight and then I had a positive
depression of the my daughter so I put
on 25 kilos and I had to lose it it took
me about eight months so and then since
then I've been trying to be in in shape
yeah and it's very important to me to be
honest so I don't know if it's anything
to do because I'm a personal trainer
even in my family my mom my sister
they're all like you know they're not
personal trainer but they are all very
sporty and very fit
so
um yeah what did you guys think of the
clip
or I don't think you said anything I
mean yeah women got a clock
so basically when the younger they have
to set it down that's what I think
you say that again when they're young
younger they have to settle down because
the older they get the more difficult is
it so it's smarter at what age do you
think dating is damn near impossible for
women maybe 40 35 40. 35 it's gonna be
difficult possible but difficult you
know yeah and what would you suggest to
women that want to compete at that age
like what could they do
but it's not smart yeah yeah never
imagine like what like what what advice
would you give them if they're they're
in that situation what do they have to
keep trying keep trying but it's
difficult you know yeah what about you
yeah I was just gonna say in that to
that um see that with with
the delusion quite frankly you know it's
almost like there's they feel they need
to be this um
this martyr and sink they all sing from
that same sheet you know him sheet of
like um you know I'm happy as I am and
there's I'll just get this energy or
this Aura of like them really trying to
convince them the person but really
themselves they're trying to convince
you know but they're not they're not and
that's why they can't answer the
questions straight yeah a simple
question like honestly
it would be so much more honest if they
just said you know I'm not happy and I
fail that relationship that I don't know
how to fix it like what did that mean I
feel comfortable saying that like I
failed that I didn't do whatever I
needed to do to make sure that that
would be the refreshing tape but but it
is so like it is so one can entertain
using this word empowering because of
how people use it but it is impact it's
much more empowering in that way and I
think just taking personal
responsibility
otherwise everything else is literally
victimhood you either take 100
responsibility for the way your life is
and the way it is and or you are a
victim of your circumstances that is
literally how I see life that's true and
in that space there isn't really any
upset there is just okay so what am I
gonna do about it now I'm all about
action results what am I going to do
about it now yes yes but then again that
is a that's more of a masculine thing
here we go
and you know have this mindset and this
way of thinking but not bring it into a
relationship with a man and and yeah
so it takes a man and a woman to make a
man or a woman so yes it's not
necessarily A Bad Thing King I sent you
one more video to react to oh
when you have a second I don't get the
feeling it's going to be a fresher
feeling no no not fashionable but
um no I just feel like um
if people were more honest now then
because this is a type of media so
people who are more honest with
themselves on these platforms people in
society would be more honest with
themselves why do you think people are
not
because they know that it's going out to
all these to however many people I think
I think it makes them look bad yes
to look bad and nobody like nobody wants
to admit that like that they look bad or
that they're bad at something and that
is what keeps you looking back yeah
because that's a that's the thing like a
lot of people think I go in on women but
it's like how are we supposed to get
better if we don't admit there's a
problem yeah and even the stuff you're
talking about like I relate to it a lot
being an athlete like you grew up as a
tomboy you don't learn a lot of the
girly stuff like it's interesting that
you grew up with um your your mom
because I found a lot of tomboys grow up
like they're Daddy's Girls well I was a
daddy's girl I mean he was I was his
firstborn so he was like yeah football
boots I've noticed that too it's a lot
of first-born girls because that's me
I'm like the firstborn girl so it's like
you're kind of a daddy's girl so they
kind of raise us to be boys a little bit
I don't know about you but you know
that's how yeah so yeah I was close
about that yeah
um so okay okay it's so late in the
great Kevin Samuels I was gonna react to
this do you like do like five minutes of
it roughly
yeah
hey sorry let me turn on some light
you gotta turn up you have to turn off
the TV in the background all right I did
hi hello
uh
I'm okay how old are you
I am 34. all right so we're talking
about pretty privilege are you single
I'm dating
uh single minute unmarried
right yes okay so for everybody who's
going in single assembly means unmarried
okay if you're not married you're single
dating okay fair uh any children
I have one okay so uh disagreement issue
what what's the problem with pretty
privileged
um I do think it exists
um
but I don't think I would be ready to
fight multiple women for it
okay
well
um how old is your child
she'll be 12 next month okay so let me
let me reverse this then why should a
man become then why should a man be
competitive
for you
why shouldn't me that's a good question
um yeah yeah
I think that
I bring good qualities
um so so do those other men everything
you're gonna say to me and Dad
you're right I'm not going to disagree
you're right
but I think it just becomes um but I'm a
woman and I'm entitled
I don't think so much entitled but I
think sometimes it can be degrading
um let me get a girlfriend having I'm
sorry didn't get a girlfriend
I don't want a girlfriend
look man let's take it away from you
okay and let's go to the Animal Kingdom
okay
the males of any species has to fight to
reproduce right
true or false
you're correct
so every male that wants to have sex
with a female just doesn't free access
he has to earn it right
correct and in order to keep reproducing
he has to continue to fight right
after he already gets her yes every
season when a woman comes at the season
there are new male Challengers to come
along
right this is The Lion King
Disney showed us this so every season
so and as long as he can win he can mate
right
correct the women don't mate with the
men who don't win correct
correct right he loses can he mate if he
loses does he continue to get to mate
no right so men have to compete
women have to submit
no women have to submit but see here's
the thing
the theme the lionesses do 90 of the
hunting
and they do all the raising of the kids
and the men are out doing what they got
to do and they come home and you got to
and you got the gazelle and the antelope
and the wildebeest made
and the only time I need to get up is if
I need to go slap that water buffalo or
with them hyenas
outside of that leave me alone and keep
them kids over there
and then when you and them and when
you're in the mood get your aunties and
your Cub sisters to keep these kids and
we're gonna go over here and have sex
for four days straight
you ever had sex with four days straight
not straight no I'm straight everything
you know taking take a 12 12 15 20
minute break
but that's the lion but see you
understand that and what comes along
with that they're more lionesses than
lion so I I say all that to say y'all
act like what y'all have to do is so
damn difficult and what we're supposed
to do is just expect it
no I don't think that is difficult per
se
but I do think that
at some point when do you see my value
like how long do I have to keep
competing and
I died
yeah uh will your mother and father
married
yeah for your grandparents married
yes how long were your grandparents
married
they're still married I mean they're
well in their 80s so it's been 10 plus
years okay your grandmother still
competes with your grandfather every day
does she know what you like the women
though uh but she still competes
but she knows what uh well
have you ever sat down and asked your
grandmother what it's like to try to
keep your grandfather
hmm yes there's been stories that he was
he was a high value man he was in the
community and all that stuff and she did
to keep him
not keep
because she had him but there were other
women that she would have to you know
put them in their place if she felt
disrespected stuff like that's fighting
to keep him
man okay a man a woman keeps a man did
you keep him happy and keep him coming
home
so your grandparents are married your
parents are married you have a child why
aren't you married at this point because
you have the kid already
right
why not so you saw the pattern and I
wasn't competing
okay but but see why had the baby
you're right I was young and dumb you're
right you okay what do you guys think
about what he was saying to compete yeah
there are too many women not enough men
so you have to compete
you know that's logic she was just
seemed to just trigger them that's just
a fact at the end of the day they don't
like maybe theoretically speaking about
but that's in effect what they're having
to do as far as actions are concerned
you know I think
again we'll bring them back to social
media when the way Society is now
that's why he takes it back to the
Animal Kingdom because there's no other
distractions it's just very simple like
okay this is how it is in order for that
species it could be anything it could be
Lions it could be whatever to continue
and that's how it works across all
um species in Animal Kingdom that's
basically the the males have to do
something but then the females or
also have to do something in order for
there to be a coming together and a
copulation to produce Offspring that's
how it just works across
the Animal Kingdom in general including
us but because we are the only species
of animals that have distractions drink
phones other social constructs that
distracts from that I agree that's where
the confusion comes in
what do you agree with
I think social media these days is makes
a big effort and
friend from like our parents generation
even when I'm comparing myself to my
daughter generation when their their her
friends come into our house whether
they're a boy or girl it doesn't make
any difference but
um I think and The Tick Tock and
Instagram and their generation the way
they talk about boys about girls
boyfriends girlfriends I think it's just
is so different I just don't even know
that generation different good or
different bad at some point good because
they're much wiser they're much more
aware but they're very you think the
kids are more aware nowadays yeah have
you seen them like yeah like you know
most kids can't read past like an eighth
grade reading level
I'm looking at my daughter and their
friends in terms of what you're saying
but I think when I'm comparing myself to
my daughter's generation I I think I
mean kids can be different I mean I have
friends that they're those who are 15 16
dad like they act like four years old so
it depends but when I compare myself
generally to I'm talking about personal
personally so I think the the new
generation they're much more aware and
they know a lot more than their age
which I'm not saying it's a good thing
and what do they know more about
um I don't know in my time I didn't even
know boyfriend since I was 16. uh so
you're saying they're starting
relationships relationships even yeah
the girls are turning the girls are like
nowadays yeah I was gonna say
it's not relationships the girls are
just the girls are everyone from
like 14 50. it's crazy that's what I'm
trying to say yes
you said wiserable you think it's wise
no no not in terms of what they know
about this yeah sex and boys but
generally when I talk to my daughter
she's the things I am learning a lot
from her you know she thinks I'm very
traditional she she thinks I'm very old
style man she doesn't agree with many
things I'm saying so I've been told of
many times what do you think is this
what did she teach you
I'm I think I'm learning first of all I
used to be very
um
what do you call it what is the word in
English
um racist
racist I I not racist in a way let me
tell you in in Iran for example
Prejudice
that is racist that is racist I'm trying
to be honest in Iran to be honest it's
just so annoying now I'm thinking about
20 30 years ago and I'm thinking what
the hell was going on in my parents mind
or so many people so many things they
say that is acceptable like you think
it's can you can you make me clear
because I think you can imagine that she
means Prejudice
um yeah like it's like oh she is oh
they're English oh they're this oh
they're Indians yeah so I I just learned
that you know since I was accusing the
new generation is more accepting so now
I'm learning a lot because every time I
say anything I say she's like Mommy this
is very racist mommy this is very this
mommy and I come to a conclusion that
actually she's right I have so many
mistakes I have to learn because I
bloody grew up in a place that everybody
was like judging judging judging
labeling labeling and now I'm actually
so feeling so blessed having her because
I'm I think I'm learning how to be had
I'm learning democracy with her because
she's just telling me off with so many
things is it democracy or is it just not
being like nasty to other people even
democracy even I'm learning democracy
from my daughter so when I say wise I'm
not saying I don't like it the way from
nine years old when she was nine years
old I told her off and she said I'm
gonna call the police we never had this
before she was nine years old and how
did they know that obviously from school
yeah but what did you say to her upset
I said please I'm like do you want to go
and live with another family do you
really want another man
can I can I have an example maybe of
something that she taught you like that
you said and she said that was wrong
it's a weird racist do you want me to
say it yeah
express yourself okay that was actually
very funny
um conversation I was in the restaurant
with my partner and her and my partner
said
um
if you have a
um or boyfriend with a dark skin I don't
know I don't know what a black yes I'm
not trying to be like you know
are you gonna get offended no I want to
know that joke so
um I don't know how can we come up with
that conversation I'm sure I was talking
about some something and my partner said
so you mean if nether comes home with a
black guy and say he's my boyfriend and
that's it and I love him and this and
that so you can what is your reaction
and my true reaction I'm so sorry please
don't you said you're not gonna get a
friend talk and
um
and it was about six years ago and I
said I looked at her and I was like are
you serious
and she looked at me the way you look at
your enemy so that look I never forget
her look and she said mommy did you know
you're the
the the most
disgusting and you're so racist she left
the restaurant she literally left here
nobody gets offended about that but
that's a racist you know no that's I'm
I'm trying to say yeah
that's what I'm saying it's like
honestly I was so lucky that nobody in
my family like better than eyelid like
because when you but Iranians are like
it is it is you know I'm glad Mandana is
here so I have all my friends Ellie how
old were you when you came to the UK uh
22 yeah see so that's the culture that
you've grown up with that like what do
you think what do you think about them I
was so stupid no I was I was really I
mean
um and that's why I sometimes I feel
like um I'm not trying to blame it on my
parents I'm not trying to blame it on
the culture but obviously that's the
place I grew up so I have to blame it on
that that's what it is you
what do you think about you know black
money when you say black man what do you
think about it I never even thought at
it because obviously that when I was
living in Iran I I hardly see any black
guy
when I came here so obviously we didn't
have conversation when I came here but
then I was looking around because
obviously England is very calm um
it's very Multicultural and I think one
of the reason I started to learn before
learning from Neda is living in the
country with diversity what did you so
the earlier you were talking about like
fat acceptance too that was something
your daughter was that something your
daughter taught you
she maybe in terms of the word maybe not
teaching is the right word but she makes
me think twice she makes me think about
what I'm saying she makes me think about
what I believe and my culture and I kind
of feel like oh my culture was I
don't like my car I don't want to be
like I don't want to be traditional
person it's not just about black people
by the way Iranians just I don't know
because of the Persian Empire
sorry our current partner is not a race
my husband was Iranian and Montana is
right there's loads of conversation
about like Jewish people in Iran yeah
yeah I mean the Greeks the Jews the like
it's yeah so it's not only so not only
one just that there is this there is
this arrogance in the Iranian culture
obviously not like individuals but just
in the culture of we're the best we did
this unfortunately yeah but I feel like
it's it's
um
it's it's a little sad to be that you
don't see anything to be proud of from
your culture you know it doesn't seem
like you find anything to be proud of
from yourself okay I do yeah no I I do
pray I don't think I've heard you say
like one pause and I always had a lot of
that no because we were talking about
the racism right that sort of things I'm
not proud at all and I'm gonna say it
again the Persian Empire did a lot I
mean
um King Cyrus the Great uh it was a fur
he wrote the first Declaration of Human
Rights was written in Persia before that
there was no human rights there was no
Declaration of it and freed slaves and
um I don't know he owned like 52 of the
world and we are say the Persian Empire
did and
um it was you know letting people choose
their religion and all of that so
there's a lot of good that's
in our culture but also don't forget we
uh there was a revolution how many years
ago what is your um what is your
relationship with your ex-husband right
now yeah no like how does like does he
also learn from your daughter too do you
think yeah oh yeah you know what she has
she has like
um anger management with her dad because
she said to me oh Mommy I think Daddy
needs um anger
um management and I'm doing it with her
with him I'm teaching him when she's
when he's angry he doesn't know what
he's saying he just quickly saying it
and she he's really upsetting me and I
know he doesn't mean to do that because
he's angry he just let it out so and I
think my ex really listening to her and
I think she's got a really you know good
impact on on both of us it sounds like
it yeah yeah that's why I went to ask
you was there an element of discomfort
for you when you got with your current
partner because obviously he's not
Iranian eating black either as you said
I I might come across that I'm not proud
of my culture there's another side of me
that I'm such a proud Persian girl
because I think Iranian people are the
most uh
friendliest and kindness and you know
they're they're always looking on a
positive side of things they're always
looking for a enjoy every moments and I
I I think there are so many good
qualities in Iranian which I if I want
to talk about it it's a lot but actually
and you're like the most like popular
Iranian TV um
aren't you TV TV channel
it is like it is literally like the most
what's the name of the channel yeah what
is it man at all man at all yeah
yeah there's a lot of good stuff so so
what else um what did you guys think
about the clip that we watched about
competing
um
again it's just that narrative that
narrative is just triggered by these
words all I'm degrading myself if I have
to complete it's just the truth right I
do actually your actions and your words
are just not in alignment you know um
so it's more than that but she seemed
like a nice girl man it wasn't like one
of the the reasons yeah yeah so and he
wasn't going too hard maybe because he
was aware of that you know but I think
he's the go anyway so you know yeah
my guy
yeah no I agree yeah I mean there is
competition there is whether we like it
or not you do have to go women and men
have to compete we have to compete in
different ways but we still have to
compete because if say for example she's
in a relationship now and then she gains
a bunch that the the person that she was
when she gets into that relationship and
then she changes in a negative way
then if the man looks elsewhere is that
is that his fault is that her fault why
don't why do we have
um songs like I don't cook I don't clean
um implying that women don't have to do
anything but be themselves who sings
that cardi B yeah I don't listen to
cardi B like women should not really
well
we shouldn't get me didn't it right the
kind of money she's got she probably get
for making it so yeah I don't listen I
suppose it applies to her isn't it but
yeah but but then obviously that message
you know gets transmitted to people who
aren't in a position and then they end
up in their 40s and 50s like I'm happy
I'm going off you know
she she said she don't cook she don't
clean but let me tell you how I got this
ring and then Meg comes in talking all
the sexual stuff that whap yeah yeah
yeah
no that's the crazy part is they're
lying cardi B just talked about how she
was gonna step away from her rap career
to spend more time with her family yeah
yeah and it's the same
I don't really listen to female artists
I'm not gonna lie I don't really apart
from the old school like Aretha Franklin
no question would you give up monogamy
for a man
give up monogamy what is that like he He
Cheats
yeah I know I don't think I can trust
that guy again no I would just I'm too
jealous I'll kill people are you
monogamous now
yes I am yeah so in a way it's like in a
way aren't you not monogamous now
like a situationship it's not monogamous
like usually the girl is monogamous but
the guy isn't
I had to have this like thought too but
it's like if you've ever been in a
situationship in a way you're sharing a
guy
she's really thinking right now yeah but
I'm I'm not in I wouldn't be you know
like committed relationship with someone
and it's like yeah it's us and
um and then be okay with him sleeping
with anyone else would you be enough
okay I didn't say okay with it but what
about accept it enough
even if I wanted to like I don't like I
don't judge other people who do maybe I
would like to want to but I'm telling
you like someone would die I I think I
think most girls would for the right guy
except I'm not saying about me they
might go crazy okay here's the thing
about me I am a little bit oblivious
because I'm very much in my own I I
always say I've never been treated of
not that I know of maybe I'm so
oblivious like I would not check a man's
phone I mean he if he did cheat and he'd
be up so down for me he would be so dumb
for me to find like I don't check a
man's phone or like okay
yeah if I did find out something on him
with someone else I honestly I don't
think I would accept it I would like to
be like why like why did you do that
because man like to yeah but I I
would do that four days straight I would
I don't know why most women say no like
why wouldn't you I had one friends he
was like really men like to new
girls
like multiple you know but if you don't
love them you know I I tell you I coach
a lot of men I coach a lot of men
and go through the whole thing of
meeting a new woman and no no okay I
have a question do you think most men if
they're in like Tiger Woods position
because I actually no I used to I used
to think like you I used to think oh
they wouldn't have like like I know
these guys that would never cheat but
it's like most of those guys aren't in
the position where women are chasing
them down and hunting them down I don't
know I've seen those guys and some of
them don't yeah
I've literally seen those guys I've hung
out with those guys I've got a lot of
male friends and they I mean they're
exceptions but I just don't but then I
wouldn't go out with somebody like in
time that's why I wouldn't go out with a
footballer even if I could I mean when I
was younger I could but I wouldn't I why
would you want to go out with the guy
who does have women throwing themselves
on him all the time like what she said
about pre-selection but then I was gonna
say now like if the guy high value
whatever whatever your kept you'd have
to worry about anything you can just
play football all day and then come home
do four days straight yeah now and then
on on the fifth day he's with Becky from
the local news no we're done what is it
that no Becky with a good hair really
and it sounds like a pretty good life
yeah no you're telling me so you're 40.
you're 42 you have a dog and now you get
you get to just be a stay-at-home wife
just made me think no just once a week
is good luck we're gonna have to get the
police up here again
definitely he's not gonna have to get
the footage but no mm-hmm no that's like
that's what I'm saying like my no
okay
I would be too jealous I would I am way
too
probably arrogant to know
if you listen to what you had to say
remember what you said before about
listening yeah but if he needs new
whatever like if you need to go and have
it like I no I can't live with that I
can't live with that yeah see listen I'm
also a German here how I was cleaning
this that is the other thing like
I can't that even if I could get over it
emotionally which I don't think I could
I could not get over the germs and the
the disgustingness of sleeping around I
cannot tell you yeah but it's so
interesting because in a way like you
you had a cat you had yeah you mean you
talked about a casual relationship so
essentially most women have like
essentially you are you're getting over
that now no but if I've made the
commitment yeah but no that would be
different for me
what's the difference
um
the difference would be in yeah there's
a commitment I've given my word you've
given your word and we're going to be
exclusive
and then if you go and do that behind my
back no
okay I know I would want to know why no
I
I think even good guys would have a hard
time if they're in a position where
women are throwing at themselves at them
you wouldn't throw it themselves at him
all the time I wouldn't but the guy
you're with probably is that's my point
it's like the guy you're with he said
he's athletic he said he's got a good
job you said he's tall like he probably
is in a position where women are
throwing themselves at him that's like
three out of five things that you want
mostly yeah like that's all right then
I'll I'll forget about him
no you got me thinking no no I wouldn't
I I I'll probably actually
you're right I'll ask him about that I
don't know so I think me and myself
no it's just I had a guy point this out
to me once like that like women will say
they won't accept like non-monogamy yet
most women have been in a situationship
at some point which is non-monogamy so
it's kind of like a double-edged but I
have friends that their their husband
just cheated on them a few times and
they're still living together
yeah I know a lot of girls yeah I mean
think about it it's like okay if you're
if you're like 45 right 50 40 let's say
45 and you get into a relationship with
a guy or you've been with a guy and you
find out he cheated and he pays for
everything it's like what so you're
gonna leave what's on the other side now
you get to work for the next 30 40 years
and this is why I'm saying yeah
like that's what I'm saying would a man
stay with a woman who cheated on him
but cheating is different for men yeah
but but yeah that's what I I think my
brain is like a matter I could not get
over that like I am not yeah maybe
maybe you couldn't my brain doesn't have
that part where he could accept that I
couldn't you but do you see what I'm
saying I think
saying though but you're in a
situationship now and so in a way you
are accepting it
you think about that
you know what I'm saying because it's
it's just like it's a contradiction
because you're saying I could never
accept it but if you're in a
non-monogamous relationship I'm not in a
relationship it's a type of relationship
right situation situation I'm not
trying to shame you for it I think I
think it's really cool
that's why I'm going to end it thank you
very much
yeah
it's just interesting how I'll talk to
girls about this and they'll be like no
I would never I would never accept that
and then a lot of those gross same girls
are in situationships and if you're in a
situation
yeah I don't think I could I would like
to be one of those I don't think I
physically could do it
but it's again it's still a
contradiction because you are
you know
so you have it in you
you know no because I don't know
you don't know if I yeah if I knew
that's what I'm saying oblivious I don't
I don't stalk man I don't check the
phone I don't like I I don't would you
look together what about if you just
looked the other way and you know he
might but no
I I would say
80 it isn't but then I don't know
[Music]
I have reason to believe he isn't
but I don't know 100 he might be
you're just trusting it
no it's not even true
no it's not even trust it's just I'm
just looking at the reality and putting
yeah and
I don't think he would be but he could
be could be but if I did see it or if I
had evidence or if I did even think no
it probably is no I would I'm just
asking I would step up if he doesn't
care about you he's gonna tell the truth
I I asked him kind of
four or five months in and he said he
wasn't hmm
but I haven't asked him recently oh but
I know you said that the the headache
that you gave him was within six months
and then four or five months yeah you
asked him if you're sleeping with anyone
else so yeah maybe after I gave my
headache
you said you were not in relationship
with no but she's saying I'm still in a
situationship but do you agree that
you're in a situation
oh yeah I am in a situation
did you know do you do you know it to be
true that he isn't sleeping with anyone
else I don't know 100 no okay do you
guys are trying to break up these
relations
we have a case studies
it's good the point she's making I'm I
get it and I 100 like agree like
um that's why I don't I don't judge well
I don't think women who stay with them
men are true I don't think oh my God you
should leave him I have I don't you know
what's interesting we had a guy
um who
um he talked about that
he would break up with girls because he
just felt like he couldn't stay faithful
to them like he just couldn't do it no
no and this is a dude that paid for
everything he like 100 would take care
of the bills and
um the
and he ended up like marrying this last
girl because she said she could accept
it and that girl on DOTA I mean she
ended up winning when you think about it
because she got the deed to the house
she got the uh well if that's your game
yeah I mean
I guess so you do have your own money I
guess that maybe that's what it doesn't
appeal to me that doesn't mean anything
to be honest for him to pay for
everything well um
and then you can just buy new football
boots no I'd rather have it to myself it
depends what is important for for that
for that yeah for me it's more important
to have them to myself than having but
even even if it's just looks like a guy
you're really attracted to even if it's
height like whatever buff you know I
mean most I mean either way it most guys
that you want there aren't enough like
more women want them yeah you know it's
usually not just you yeah no 100 I say
that Tim I was like I bet audio all you
see my friends won't sleep with the 100
um okay I think we're gonna close out oh
I didn't realize how late it is Jesus
um okay
um why don't you guys give me your final
thoughts of starting here and then go
around
um this is you can plug any social media
anything any final things you want to
say I'm sorry about what sorry
final thoughts about anything Michelle
about the show and so the the funny
thing is
um I've been to obviously different
shows and I love cameras and I've been
different cameras and stuff but this is
my first experience for with with
podcasts broadcasting and I found it
amazing because I think when you talk
about things and it's one of those
environment is very exclusive that you
can feel and I feel so you know you're
so easy and you know come make us feel
so at home that you feel like you can
talk about it and you're quite
challenging us you challenge me quite
well and I find it difficult but from
the other side I find it amazing because
you made me think about so many things
and you all with the conversation I
never thought before and I kind of you
kind of make me aware of actually and
tonight probably when I'm going to bed
I'm going to think oh when she asked me
that question that's interesting
actually I am this or I am that or maybe
I'm not comfortable talking about this
and that so for me it was like a
wonderful experience and it was just
thank you for having me thanks for
coming thank you
yeah overall I'm well aware of you know
your work and stuff and uh yeah grateful
to be on here well my friend told me do
you want to come or not I thought he was
joking so I'm jumped at the opportunity
uh yeah let's let's do a bit of plugging
yeah so am Alpha mic Global Let's uh
property management company so holler at
me for all you landlords out there that
need your man your properties managed
and uh yeah thanks for having us on the
show pal then absolute pleasure thank
you do you mind if I add my Instagram
yeah go ahead uh it's um it's move like
Ellie so
muscular like underscore Ellie Ellie's
e-l-i-e
um it's been great being here it was
lovely meeting everyone
except for
a little scenario there but at least it
was entertaining and um yeah thank you
all for coming except her
[Applause]
um no it's really it's really great like
being with you like I've seen obviously
I've seen you on YouTube in there and um
um it's just been really great just
everything that we spoke about and thank
you for just the opportunity I love I
love uh giving my opinions so so it was
great to just be here and be able to um
give some opinions and I really hope
I hope it makes a difference to the
younger generation from our mistakes the
older generation yeah thank you for
coming yeah thank you um it's been a
great experience um great conversation
great meeting everyone
hope to do it again
thank you for the opportunity it's time
to go home
[Laughter]
thank you for having me I think this is
the most diverse was anyone here born in
England you no no
Greece this is like the most diverse
panel I've ever had I think ever was
anyone born in the same country no
everyone's done but for me and Ellie
were born in Iran okay okay yeah I think
only was the oh the one that left she
was born in England to be honest it was
a good backup for me
but it was a pleasure to be here thank
you so much for coming um guys like the
video on your way out I'm gonna read
this last um super chats before we end
the show I think there's just like one
or two
um also guys a big shout out to security
for keeping us safe from crazy living
also guys
um we're going to be doing a meet-up
soon in England so if you want to come
to one of our meetups make sure you sign
up for the Google form um so you are
um
you know notified when we do do that
that should be in the chat I think Doug
usually shares it
um okay uh I can't read your username
but from one security guard to another
great job I am the same way I don't care
for water works but I do my job you
deserve a tip it would be nice to work
together one day maybe one day in the
USA by the way my name is Ivan Carlos
Norm McDonald's broke the Tiger Woods
cheating down um Joey bless her heart 10
minutes in the episode and I guess is
already trying to compare her personal
Circle experience to the majority and is
already missing the point of the topic
Manny also first generation
um warning label Ty pods Walt as a six
foot six figure gen Z man I refused a
date over the age of 28 one year minimum
dating and engagement at 30 fertility
drops off too much Manny F whoop whoop
that's the sound of the police morale
all you got to do is play the video back
okay
um I think that's all the announcements
I really have
um
oh we're doing a show Saturday so tune
in Saturday for our next show
um we're next week we're going to try to
move the podcast an hour earlier so
we're not up as late so
um expect it to start around eight we're
hoping so like the video on your way out
guys subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from them than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though if it goes
so deeper though because I know what
you're talking about and he has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest
unders for women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's picky or men or women
men and women are more complacent than
men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all of them and do you think men
are very like if they've they've got a
certain standard and they're more rigid
than women I think men are pickier than
women 100 definitely but they will not
marry they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last
vagina films
right yeah whatever
when I finished it I felt very degraded
I felt very like why did I actually do
that now I know there's girls out there
who do that they don't feel that way
that is perfectly fine you do you you
feel the way you feel but me personally
like like in the future how like when I
have kids and all the future and if my
kids found out about that they'll
probably get bullied in school there are
people like oh your mom doing this your
mom doing that and your man as well he's
not going to if you don't respect
yourself and you're selling your body
online I can't speak for everyone I can
just speak for myself if you're selling
your body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
foreign